so we got some fbi whistleblowers
they've come out and they've said that
the fbi top brass told them not to
investigate hunter biden and his laptop
because they didn't want to influence an
election so instead just let a crooked
guy win i guess
it's shocking but probably not shocking
to a lot of people the idea i guess is
that they're concerned in 2016 when they
did the whole hillary clinton email
thing they may have swayed an election
well here you go they were instructed
not to investigate so we will be talking
about that plus marjorie taylor green
got swatted yup dude
swatting is an attempted murder as far
as i'm concerned because people have
died it may not be as direct of a threat
or act of terror as like literally
showing up to say like brett kavanaugh's
house but it is
extreme and if we're getting that point
where
individuals are targeting sitting
members of congress in such a way i got
to tell you man look january 6 was bad
it was a riot but this is direct
targeting of a politician it's it's it's
it's all in this space of dramatic
escalation turns out according to police
being reported the individual who
swatted marjorie taylor green was a
trans rights activist so we'll be
talking about that uh and and so much
more
crazy days donald trump is celebrating
that he's got all of his endorsements
won
even democrats congratulations trump you
endorsed democrats and they won i guess
sure whatever before we get started
however my friends head over to stronger
bones and life.com and pick up your
ageless multi-collagen from biotrust how
do i stay so young and chipper why my
friends i consume biotrust ageless
multicollagen and also the keto stuff
too but this is for the multi-collagen
so go to stronger bones in life.com
you'll get 51 percent off this is
collagen you need it for your joints
your skin your hair your bones your
nails all of that good stuff if you want
to look young and supple you'll need
this go to stronger bones in life.com
and you'll get a 60 day money back
guarantee the healthy aging support of
collagen in its ideal forms
five key types of collagen you need from
four different sources
hydrolyzed collagen peptides meaning
better and faster digestibility to
support maximum benefits and for every
order today they will donate a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kid hungry.org to date biotrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
hungry kids please help biotrust hit
their goal of 6 million meals this year
it is non-gmo and free of artificial
colors flavors preservatives and
sweeteners free of gluten antibiotics
rbgh rbst nearly no odor or taste no
clumping you'll get free shipping with
every order free vip live and help live
health and fitness coaching from
biotrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life and their free
e-report the 14 foods for amazing skin
with every order again shout out
biotrust thanks for sponsoring the show
over at strongerbonesandlife.com and i
must say
head over to tipcast.com become a member
because we're going to have an epic
members only show tonight after the live
show so if uh you want to hang out see
the uncensored not so family-friendly
version that will be at 11 p.m over at
timcast.com as a member you're directly
supporting our work you'll get access to
the cast castle vlog tuesdays at seven
which actually we actually just filmed a
really funny bit involving chickens but
maybe we'll talk about no we shouldn't
give it away
and um we also have tails from the
infrared world we were able to film an
amazing bit for cast castle with our uh
current guest james lindsey is it dr
james lindsey it is dr james lindsey
it's a little embarrassing these days
though to admit that you stayed in
academia that long nah and you got a phd
so uh for those that don't know who you
are who are you i'm dr james lindsay
that's concise okay
well that explains it tim i'm dead i
died they kicked me off of twitter
that's it your digital self is gone
that's right r.i.p me rip james you want
to pull that microphone up a little bit
sure
i always do this yeah ripped james look
at this yeah look at that he was uh
sword fighting that's what uh
said that that's right it's getting
jacked working okay so i criticize woke
stuff i read marxism i tell people what
what marxist books say and i criticize
woke as a form of marxism i call it woke
marxism as a matter of fact that's not a
joke and there's a lot of joking
involved in what i say and do but like
critical race theory is basically woke
marxism i wrote a book in february
called race marxism that's about
critical race theory so yeah um and
right now i'm doing education theory i'm
going through that i'm diving into this
so-called queer theory which guess what
i would think of it as queer marxism um
yeah there you go yeah whole thing so
that i think everybody knows who i am
actually yeah everyone everyone because
i've been struck down like obi-wan yes
which made me much stronger of course i
sense your presence yeah i knew you
could thanks for coming we also have
hannah claire bermullo she's hanging out
hi i'm hannah claire brimley i'm a
writer for timcast.com
i'm ian crossland also happy to be here
what's up everybody james looking
forward to finding out why you got
banned from twitter i'm still shocked
still reeling let's talk more about that
in a bit we will get into it for sure i
am back this evening my hand is still
incredibly crippled oh you can't see it
there you go and sore my little t-rex
arm let's get going yikes lydia got
surgery i did yeah they broke it again
and they put bolts in it super battle
were you awake for that no no no i made
them knock me out i was like what was it
like just like fell asleep yeah it was
great it was great it just drifted off
that freaks me out you know like when
you're going for surgery it's like what
happens do you like do you dream while
they're it's enough shopping i woke up
in a surgery once no don't hurt people
doing that with their wisdom teeth it
was my wisdom teeth yeah i was put under
for that man i woke up and that like
they were like hammering to break the i
don't know if you knew they'd break your
wisdom yeah
yeah yeah yeah i wasn't i wasn't put
under for that and the guy started like
laughing like i was like i couldn't talk
my mouth was like clamped open and could
you feel it uh i felt pressure like the
hitting but no it didn't hurt and the
guy starts laughing and he's like night
night and he could see him like
and he gave me more drugs and uh
man i was like i came out of that
surgery messed up for like a day yeah i
got a
one of my couple of my wisdom teeth were
taken out very
methodically and professionally and i
was uneventful but one was impacted and
the dude had a chisel and was like
bashing again
and i was like
that's horrible anyway i was under for
mine all of mine were impacted and when
i woke up i was really stressed out
probably coming out of the anesthesia
but like
requested adamantly that they returned
my teeth to me
i don't know what it was i was like very
distressed they're like they're broken i
was like i need them eat them return
what you have stolen from
me all right let's talk about this uh we
got some news man let's talk about the
story we got from the new york post fbi
brass warned agents off hunter biden
laptop due to 2020 election according to
whistleblowers fbi officials told agents
not to investigate first sun hunter
biden's infamous laptop for months
vowing at the bureau was quote not going
to change the outcome of the election
again according to whistleblower claims
made public by uh wednesday by senator
ron johnson these new allegations
provide even more evidence of fbi
corruption and renew calls for you to
take immediate steps to investigate the
fbi's actions regardless of the laptop
johnson wrote in a letter
to justice department inspector general
michael horwitz according to the senator
individuals with knowledge had told his
office that local fbi leadership had
slow walked the laptop investigation
after the computer was recovered from a
wilmington delaware repair shop in
december of 2019
we got this story from the examiner jim
jordan says more fbi whistleblowers are
coming forward every other week here's
where it gets crazy
the fbi said not to investigate very
serious crimes which literally involved
the man running and there and and the
excuse was we don't want to interfere in
election it's like no you're literally
interfering you're you're pausing your
job
not bringing criminal justice
accountability to a corrupt family
because the person's running for office
at the same time right now donald trump
who we all know is going to be running
is having his home raided by the fbi and
they're cheering for it so very clearly
i just can i just what's the what's
what's the word for you know when we've
done uh hundreds of shows
thousands of segments and we just talk
about political civil war conflict the
weaponization of the doj all of that
stuff and like this
is it certainly should be
a a cold splash of water in the face of
the average person and if this doesn't
do it for you like to somebody and they
don't believe it there there's no
there's no change in their minds you
actually have the fbi whistleblower
saying we were told not to investigate a
hunter biden laptop which includes joe
biden meanwhile donald trump currently
right now is having his home rented okay
there you go it's busted what do we do
we're do we do what we do which is i'm
glad you pointed out doing nothing is a
form of doing something often sitting by
and watching evil take place is an
active thing you do so
they certainly influence the election by
not getting involved or by choosing to
ignore it that's a form of influence
like it would be if uh let's say there's
a house on fire
and uh it's got evidence of a crime in
it and the firefighters are like
i'm not gonna put that fire out because
then somebody might find that evidence
and use that against the person who
lives there so we rather just let the
place burn down i guess that makes no
sense the fbi they're law enforcement
they're supposed to say we will stop
criminal activity this means
hunter biden could have been actively
engaged in criminal activity
for a year
and the fbi was like well you know but
uh you know joe biden's going to run for
office so we better just let him do it
there you go welcome to uh
what's what's what's the word for it
what do we what do we call this era in
american history
is there a word we can use i don't know
i don't know i mean it's just such a
like partisan play right we don't want
to influence an election depending on
who's running and also who we don't want
to run it's just so strange and open i
am surprised that the fbi uh
isn't
i i was really surprised when the
obvious answer after mar-a-lago was
people people being like we don't know
that we trust the fbi why are we letting
this organization run this way and the
response was no you can't say that about
this giant government institution like
it seems like it's clearly
biased to favor democrats right now and
to protect democrats who might be uh
conducting or are
acting illegally but obviously par
choosing to investigate trump and other
republicans it's just
how can you even trust the system when
it's so obviously biased but they don't
care no they don't i think
what they're really trying to do is
protect the liberal economic order which
is this global you know
thing we've had since 1946 basically to
prevent world war three they and whether
i don't think it i don't personally
think it's like a democrat republican
thing i think they're trying to hold up
the old order i i i disagree somewhat i
agree that there are powerful interests
in entities that clearly want the
liberal international economy to stay
afloat but uh you know people are
chatting about sam harris as a good
example of exactly what is going on here
sam harris he said the quiet part out
loud he should he and then he tried
walking it back because he realized what
he was saying what he was admitting to
he said he did he would not care if
hunter button at the corpses of children
in his basement it's like you realize
who's giving this guy money and who's
funding this and like what that
investigation would actually lead to but
they don't
care
this is this is
they're psychopaths i i don't know like
what's what's the mental
uh trump derangement syndrome is is that
the the official diagnosis you have
people who are like
sam harris literally saying hunter biden
could be abusing and murdering kids but
trump once once had a university and
that's worse he actually said those
words he said i wouldn't care if they
were corpse of children hundred biden's
basement
what trump did with trump university was
way worse than anything he could hunter
biden could have done and it's like what
like the worst case scenarios trump
opened a fake university and ripped some
people off and that's worse than joe
biden funneling u.s taxpayer money to
ukraine and getting us involved in war
and surrendering in afghanistan among
other things um
among a few other i mean so you asked
what is what is this this period in
america's history called it's the
attempted uh hopefully attempted color
revolution of the united states weimar
america i mean well one wishes actually
it's worse than that it's it's exactly
the same kind of thing they pulled in
ukraine a couple you know like 2014 or
whatever we're talking about
a revolution that they are
attempting to take over
the country illegitimately i would
opinion yeah and what i was saying uh
earlier is uh you know i've talked about
civil war but i should revise that
because civil war implies two factions
competing right now it just looks like
it's a revolution so you you know you
look at soviet russia you look at
germany those are those were not civil
wars the political conflict ultimately
resulted in one faction just instantly
winning without a civil war so
to be a bit more pessimistic the result
of everything that's going on would be
revolution but i i do kind of feel like
they're losing so i do too and so i mean
another way that we could characterize
this since you have me here and i talk
about marxist theory all the time is
that what we're actually living through
is kind of the the logic of this essay
from 1965 called repressive tolerance i
bring this up a million times i brought
it up here before but the logic of
repressive tolerance is that the left
must be tolerated at any this is
actually you can look up the essay
itself it's the thesis statement we must
extend tolerance to the left we must not
extend tolerance to the right they say
that this includes the level of violence
marcus herbert marcus is one who wrote
this in 65 he said you know it's never
ethical to engage in violence but since
when's when does ethics make history and
so he excuses violence and he has a long
paragraph where he mentions violence
like 13 times and he says there's a big
difference between revolutionary
violence and reactionary violence and
what the deal is we must extend
tolerance to the left and not to the
right and he says to the point with the
right that what you're actually trying
to stop and this is a hunter biden story
right what you're trying to stop is the
thought from entering the potential
reactionary's mind
he says that it involves not just
censorship but pre-censorship you don't
even want the right wing which is
everybody who's not a revolutionary on
the left is the right wing by the way
you don't even want the thought to enter
their mind that would allow anything
except left-wing power to take control
and so we live in the logic of that
essay i would guess that our department
of justice and our fbi have taken this
horrifically totalitarian document from
the 60s as an instruction manual and
what you see then is you see this uh
cracking down on president trump which
by the way i was on a flight recently to
california i'm sitting next to a
lifelong she's in her you know 70s
lifelong california liberal
married to her professor the whole thing
right so you're thinking some left as
she starts talking about trump she's
like well first she asked me what i do i
say i go around i talk about marxism i
study marxism she's like well i don't
know anything about marxism i'm thinking
that's why you probably support it
but um
she says that she's asking me do you
think trump's a dictator i think he
might have been an attempted dictator
this whole thing and then she says but
this raid on his house was too far
so you talk about shaking people loose
and freaking people out she's like this
isn't what we do in america
like she they shouldn't have raided his
house and i was like wow that's
something now i heard a podcast with
like a literal neocommunist one of the
people that's in league with that
literal neo-communist that aoc shared a
megaphone with after uh samara taylor or
whatever name is after the roe v wade
decision
and um
this podcast was with an educator who's
also an open communist henry giroux who
like changed all of american education
to be what it is today and in that
podcast she's like the very fact that
they raided his house
means that there must be evidence that
he's done all this wrong stuff and i was
like wow the dividing line in our
society is people who think the
institutions are still legitimate like
sam harris and people who don't uh who
who have questions at least about them
well so i often uh
i eschew the left right paradigm in fact
that's what my wikipedia says about me
and then uh you know people argue but
tim talks about the left and the right
all the time and i'm like they're
colloquial terms that don't really
reference politics they reference
as i think you put it well revolutionary
and i don't i don't think reactionary to
be completely honest because um
there are reformers right right you know
with the the the leftist view everybody
accept themselves as from his
reactionaries as they're right and
literally it's like right-wing
extremists which of course we hear from
our military we hear from uh the doj et
cetera i often uh say it's the those who
are discerning and those who are not
simply put there are people who will
hear information and say i'll check into
that and there are people who hear
information and go whoa
crazy yeah exactly that's crazy and so
then you end up with um
michael brown and they go whoa
that's chris and then we go what's the
report say oh the report says hands up
don't you wasn't true then you get
people who are like jesse smilette
whoa
and then we're like okay that sounds
nuts like right away when the story came
out we were like dude
trump supporters at 3 a.m in sub in in
in freezing weather in chicago in a work
district not a residential one attacking
a d-list celebrity i really don't
believe i stayed in that hotel in
january it was like eight degrees i had
covered it was awesome
that's great it was no sorry it was like
minus eight degrees let me no nobody's
getting attacked there let me give you a
really good example actually and um i
wanna i wanna shout out to our our good
friend vosh actually and um that's only
half vashti nova right
it's only half sarcastic i do respect
that he was willing to come on the show
that we disagree with him but he tweeted
i delayed paying off my student loans
just in case debt relief got passed and
now i find out you're not eligible if
you're a famous youtuber who makes one
million dollars a day honestly and he's
obviously joking so i responded with omg
this is exactly the left vosh is rich
and wants free money this is proof biden
is a communist very clearly we are both
just being silly
but
wow the responses from people who
instantly believed i was telling like
there are people on the left who
believed vosh was being serious and
they're going he makes a million dollars
a day and there are people responding to
me and they're like look at these
right-wing grifters look what they're
saying and it's just like that's it
right there did you know if he gave a
million dollars a day to people then
america could be everybody could have a
million dollars that's right he's the
one stopping you you know it's all
voucher's fault you know what i love the
most though is when someone says like
they're like
what do they say um michael bloomberg
spent 500 million dollars on the
election there were 300 million people
living in this country he could have
given everyone a million dollars like do
your math again
well millions as a unit 16.
right now you have 10 eggs and everybody
can have eggs it's millions it's just a
unit yeah it's simple and so this is you
know so to go back to your point
you know you're mentioning it's the
people who trust the institutions people
who don't it's like yeah that's that's
all part of it um i refer to it as a
cult it is a cult it's 100 a cult i
would love to talk about how like not
just religious but cultish uh this whole
like
whether we want to do with woke whether
we want to deal with like this kind of
like leftist arrangement cult like sam
harris has i would guess i don't know
i've been out with him but once but i i
can't guess his mind but i would suppose
he has a group of people to whom he's
very interested in maintaining their
esteem yeah and there are let me tell
you as you would also be able to tell
people there are certain things that you
just can't espouse and then before
people decide they don't like you
anymore like people just they think
you've lost your mind they think that
you've uh that you're a terrible person
they disassociate from you and but
that's mostly on the left like it's a
liz it it's just on the right for sure a
little bit but i mean
it's the exception how did one get here
is that right yeah so you know i've been
cut off i've been i've been canceled
from all kinds of people people i
thought were friends but you know all
sorts of stuff because well what did i
do all right i said that maybe trump is
an all right
candidate for trump isn't that bad maybe
orange man good you know who knows
maybe making america great again is a
good idea because it's kind of a on the
decent right now if we don't kind of
curb some of these things i i was uh
you know i i've been
talking about music lately because we're
releasing this song and uh it's fresh in
my mind so for those that are wondering
it's like why is tim bring it up again
well it's like it's in my mind we're
working on this project and i tweeted
this today like
there are people who are scared to say
things they like that's weird to me so
nickelback is a really good example um
because everybody jokes about how awful
nickelback is it's like dude they have
ten six top ten i'm sorry they have six
top tens on billboard hot 100 and they
have one billboard hot 100 number one
for four weeks for one month they had a
song on the number the number one song
like people clearly like nickelback yeah
but it became a meme where i was like
you weren't cool if you admitted to
liking them well that's because they
went huge
maybe i'll but i'll say this you know so
i was like
people clearly like them not really my
gem i've never been like a fan of them
but i but they did a cover of devil went
down to georgia which is mind-blowingly
good it's one of the best covers of the
song i've ever heard the guitar playing
is crazy the vocals are fantastic
they cut the chorus out though and i'm
like
come on man charlie you know charlie
daniels band it's a classic song but it
was really really good it's amazing i
got no problem saying that and there are
people tweeting at me being like this
explains it aha he admits it and i'm
like do you think i care i genuinely
enjoy that song i will tell you that
yeah i'm not worried about you not
liking me because you do nothing for my
life there's a term for this what is it
it's preference falsification
it's that in order to appear socially
acceptable you falsify your actual
preferences that you you like a
nickelback cover or song or band period
but you know that the people you're
talking to will think you're not cool if
you do that and so you falsify your
preferences as a it's crazy a social
maneuver that's crazy to me and i
actually think that people like sam
harris falsified their preferences or
maybe they didn't but maybe they just
got sucked in by the psyops but a lot of
people falsified their preferences about
trump to the point where they believed
it
like it drove him if you live in
crazytown for long enough you go crazy i
mentioned this the other day a couple
times a video of a woman asking three
women what is a woman and um i think it
was meant while she responded these
women all clearly know what a woman is
but they're trying to reconcile the
definition with what they're allowed to
say that's right yeah so it's like
definition falsification or something um
a lot of people miss by the way the big
point of what is a woman a lot of people
don't understand what that's about and
just to point out
kantanji brown jackson actually told us
when marsha blackburn caught her out
said was a woman she said oh i don't
know do i look like a biologist or
whatever what she said exactly about
invoking an expert what she said is i
can't answer that question without
asking an expert yeah in other words we
can't answer simple questions about
reality without an expert telling us
what the right answer is and that's
scary as hell because that's super power
grab territory right and that's exactly
what they are doing by by undermining
definitions by undermining people's
ability to say what's real and not real
or you know use words and have them mean
things you mentioned this woman on the
plane right you were saying yeah and she
said the raid on trump went too far yeah
i'm wondering if there's a point where
you know sam harris let me let me slow
down go to sam harris
he's got the most severe tds i have ever
seen
that woman does not she's probably a
normal person and just passively absorbs
information and thinks trump is bad
because she's just hearing it but then
when she hears something crosses the
line she made up her mind that's too
much for me sam harris told us there
could be corpses of children in the
basement of hunter biden he wouldn't
care and he compared him to an asteroid
that's going to destroy the earth
that's like the next
that's that's lunacy like like not not
only is that just on its face laughably
crazy but even if trump really was
hitler and like the worst dictator
possible would never amount to an
asteroid
smashing into earth and wiping out all
life as we know it yeah like bad
dictator bad we deal with bad dictator
certainly is not an asteroid coming to
wipe out the planet rip through its core
and blow it out he's speaking in
hyperbole for sure i mentioned to you it
seems like he has like either or he
needs friends or he's got a group of
insulated friends and he's in an echo
chamber he needs like people to listen
to him and tell him when he's being an
idiot sam you went too far that you know
i know you were being hyperbolic when
you said that stuff i i i
was like he would have cared if hunter
had kids in his basement of course he
wouldn't but
being hyperbolic is like exaggerating
something to prove a point whereas like
that was a really strange thing to just
state like i don't think that qualifies
as hyperbole because i think he's being
honest what was happening is he said i
wouldn't have cared if if hunter had uh
chill dead children in his basement i
would not have cared in brackets as much
uh or i wouldn't have cared i i think
it's simpler than brackets i see what
you're saying but i think it's simpler i
think it's you mentioned he's got he's
got a group of people he's trying to
pander to he's doing this public
interview he wants them to hear it
whoever they are and so he has to keep
one upping his position he has to be
bigger stronger better and in this line
of thinking it's trump is bad we must
stop trump by any means necessary in
order to pander to those people he has
to constantly expand upon his position
now he's at the point where he's like
dead kids don't care huh just got to
stop trump he's an asteroid it's kind of
like how incrementally the nazis started
first they didn't like jews then they
started taking their businesses away
then they started shipping them out then
they started shipping them to camps and
they started killing them like how it
incrementally got worse and worse so
same with sam's mind seems to have
incrementally according to what you're
saying imagine people in politics or the
fbi doing that and this is the story we
have the fbi going like well we can't go
after hunter oh but donald trump he had
documents even though he has you know
you know like unilateral
declassification powers yeah you said
did you see the thing that he they put
out that huge list of items and one of
the things that was contraband was a was
a i guess an illegal cocktail napkin
from the white house yeah they had a cop
didn't know that clinton's like move
furniture out of the white house like
this was like one of the famous things
they had to return stuff to the
residents they had moved stuff out like
i don't know we're not supposed to know
anything about it oh sorry nobody knows
anything about hillary clinton i want to
i want to get your thoughts on this
james we have the story from fox 5
atlanta marjorie taylor green was victim
of swatting at rome residence police
confirmed
so uh this is this is a terrifying story
it is that a bunch of outlets have
reported this is a prank a swatting for
those that aren't familiar i think most
of you are but just in case is when
someone calls the police and says
there's a violent crime currently taking
place so that a swat team shows up to
your house and it potentially kills you
people have died from this and it's
horrifying i can't imagine there's a
story about this guy
cops around his house he has no idea
what's going on he comes out armed the
cops shoot and kill him imagine first of
all that guy being the victim having no
idea why the cops are at your house then
think about you know i'm not saying it's
worse but that cop
who was told there's a guy who had to
murder his wife or something we need you
to save her life and he shows up and
he's like i got to stop this guy and
then it turns out someone tricked you
into killing an innocent man
talk about the nightmare scenario that
swatting is and they went after marjorie
taylor green's house this is
uh it was look i'm gonna it was a trans
activist this is the reporting was they
told the police that the reason they did
it was because they oppose her position
on on trans uh kids because marjorie
taylor green recently introduced a bill
that would make it a felony to give
transgender surgery or medication to
children
so i'm curious too uh james because you
talk about revolution and where we're at
where does this fit in with you know
their power grabs the power structures
like what is what is this
okay so
just to mention by the way the last time
i actually talked to marjorie like a
month ago and that's exactly this is
exactly the subject not swatting but but
trans activism and the surgeries and
everything to the children is exactly
what we talked about so it's kind of
funny i like marjorie um so what's going
on here
is a kind of an unbridled demonstration
of being willing to step outside of the
boundaries the normal boundaries of
society in order to get your way so
marjorie taylor green proposes a bill
this is the way that we do things if the
bill passes the bill passes there are
lots of bills that pass that people like
or don't like on either side and that's
just the name of the game maybe it
doesn't pass maybe whatever but the idea
that you're now going in
to to do this act of intimidation
that basically sends this huge signal
outright terror outright terror literal
definition there's there's a few things
there are there are some things but
there are a few things scarier than the
idea like you said of armed angry
police officers thinking something is
going on that requires desperate
measures surrounding your house or
whatever at 1am in the you know right in
the middle of the night you're asleep
you don't know what's going on and all
of a sudden this is happening and so
what this is is it's just another
another escalation in the kind of
pattern of intimidation that we're
seeing um you know
what were they doing outside the supreme
court justices houses they were
protesting but then judge kavanaugh has
a credible threat to his life involved
with this and what do you have well it
turns out
funny enough you mentioned trans
activists the exact same trans activist
who got me kicked off of twitter the
exact same one
alejandra carabello
advocated for more of this
the the intimidation tactics
intimidating of the supreme court
justices even in this environment the
exact same one so what you have is
people who are stepping outside of the
frame of society the breaking the taunt
of society to get their way and they
feel perfectly entitled to be able to do
it because they've got some trumped up
idea about uh
what do you call it systemic or
structural well demanding that you stay
within the lines oh yeah absolutely
that's the repressive tolerance again or
liberating tolerance actually we saw
this with the gravel institute
after january 6 the gravel institute
tweeted that they supported the action
but not the people the people were the
wrong ones to do it and they deleted the
tweet people were like you're saying
that you thought that was good and they
were like yup and then they were like
y'all are crazy and then they deleted it
like okay maybe we shouldn't admit that
that's the crazy thing
you have people who are lucid they're
they're they're they understand what
they're doing they know how the machine
works they know why they're claiming you
can't do it and while they do it but
then you have the dumb people who
mindlessly march along completely
clueless and don't care sam harris comes
off to me like
he is
you know what's what's what's the
opposite of sentient
[Laughter]
sam harris comes off to me as the
fulfillment of the the critical theory
magnum opus called dialectic of
enlightenment to be honest with you
explain so dialectic of enlightenment
was this book written in 44 and
rewritten and published again in 47 by
uh max horkheimer and theodore adorno
the two kind of principal critical
theorists of the era
and um what they said is that you know
you start off with the enlightenment you
enter into this phase denouncing myth
and entering into rationality but what
happens is through the dialectical
process of transformation of
enlightenment rationality itself becomes
its own mythology and you literally
enter into this new kind of religious
order of rationality that completely
divorces you from being genuinely
rational you're now operating within
this myth and i read this book and i was
like this is insane this is just crazy
and then i looked at sam harris and i
was like oh
okay so so uh maybe what's the opposite
of lucid uh
murky murky clouded well so the way i
see it is sam harris is dude it's almost
like looking through cataracts instead
of lucid vision it's like he's got this
fog in front of his eyes but i don't
think that's the right way to describe
it because hypnosis is a better way to
do this yeah that's a good way to put it
because even if your eyes are cloudy you
can be thinking clearly yeah even if
your information is bad you wouldn't say
something is insane about dead kids he's
he's in a state of like cult hypnosis
that has stripped away his individuality
his agency and now he's just mindlessly
droning along
there there are people like that but
then there are people who are fully
aware they're breaking the rules and
they know it and they don't care like i
mentioned the gravel institute oh yeah
totally totally um so this is something
a lot of people don't really fully
appreciate about our current moment is
that we're actually not dealing with
just politics at all we're dealing with
it's not even like the soul or the
future of america we're dealing with two
fundamentally different conceptions of
what it means to be a human being uh or
literally down to religious roots of
what it means to be a person and uh
kind of the american answer kind of
comes from john locke who in essence is
like well none of us are god so none of
us deserve political authority so we're
going to secure life liberty and
property so people can think for
themselves and disagree amongst one
another because we don't have all the
answers and so the american system
really the question is who deserves
political authority and thomas jefferson
and benjamin franklin these guys meet
together in their answer at james
madison we're like
nobody deserves it but we'll lend it to
you under these conditions and that's
called a republic yeah but the answer
these leftists believe fundamentally
believe marxist-style leftists
fundamentally believe that they're the
only enlightened conscious people on the
planet that understand how supposed to
work so they not only should have
political authority they're entitled to
political authority so they get to step
outside of the rules because they're
fully entitled to have political
authority over everything you want to
read that one yeah okay so this is it's
pronounced gravel gravel okay the gravel
institute um when was that uh one eight
twenty one so january eighth uh two days
after january six okay got you
but if leftist had stormed the capital
you'd support it in scare quotes yes
they are fighting for a good cause
fascists are fighting for a very bad
cause this should not be difficult this
is the this is the thesis statement of
repressive tolerance written right again
that's exactly the thesis statement if
we went down to the thesis statement of
repressive tolerance in the essay he
says that liberating tolerance can be
summarized in basically a single
sentence and he says that
tolerance must be extended to movements
from the left and must be withdrawn from
movements from the right which is
exactly why
they never seem to complain about the
soviet union or the culture revolution
and these other countries that currently
exist that are still communist but
they're they're always screaming nazi
germany that's right that's exactly
right the fascists the fascists that's
right they they never
uh
recognize that if you actually read
marx's different stages of history where
you bail out of capitalism you have your
revolution and you have a dictatorship
of the proletariat that's the next stage
that's called socialism that socialism
is actually a fascist state that is
supposed to dialectically unwind to a
utopia which it's not going to do
there's a meme
and this female journalist personality
leftist tweeted
people often point out how socialism has
has failed in so many countries but if
it doesn't work you don't just give up
you keep trying and then someone respond
like they said like like cooking if you
make a mistake you just start you know
try again and someone responded with
like oops burn the souffle and it's a
picture of
skulls yeah yeah brutal murder well i
mean that is actually their idea so the
idea is i mean to get deeper into the
philosophy behind it that you have this
thing out floating in the world this is
hegel okay so hegel proceeds marks
mark's retools hegel and makes it
material hegel's idea is that there's
this literal concept of god called the
absolute idea so it's the perfected idea
the absolute you know platonic form of
how everything in the universe should
operate it's it's the deity but we don't
have access to that so it splits into
two sides the theoretical idea and the
practical idea the theoretical idea is
our idea about it our guess about it our
theory or how we think the world's
supposed to work practical ideas how it
actually gets implemented usually
through the state
by the way he said that the state is a
divine idea as it exists on earth and
this is just to help you understand if
you ever see the left start gloating
about praxis yes that's right and so
what the idea of praxis is supposed to
bring theory and practice together again
so the theoretical idea and practicality
are supposed to come together which
reinstitutes the absolute
so the idea is that when you put the
soviet union into practice
and 30 something 40 something million
people die what you were doing is you
you're exposing the contradiction
between the theoretical and the
practical so what you're actually doing
is learning more about why it didn't
work this time
and so you think those people are in
hegel's world words i mean literally
this is a quote from hegel history uses
people and then discards them so they
were discarded on the altar of the god
of history sacrificed to the god of
history so that history can move to its
perfected end point you should watch
full metal alchemist
you know i no i know what it is i've
seen like some parts of it uh but i
haven't actually watched it all the way
through but i'm sure that this is going
to relate because what hegel was was a
hermeticist which is an alchemist
there's two two uh anime is it animes
that i recommend or manga um attack on
titan and full metal alchemist because
they directly deal so uh fullmetal
alchemist brotherhood which is the
actual it follows the manga and i know a
lot of people out there they might not
be fans of any of this stuff graphic
novels or whatever but seriously
consider this because what it deals with
is
powerful elites who want to sacrifice
the people for more power that's full
metal alchemist and i want to spoil it
if you're going to check it out but it
very much deals with this how the
population of throughout history are
sacrificed for more and more power and
then attack on titan
it's funny someone posted a meme of
jordan peterson saying you should watch
attack on titan and it's not real but uh
if you're a fan of jordan peterson and
you watch that show you're going to be
like i wouldn't be surprised if you
actually did say it because it deals
with privilege and historical racism and
all of that stuff in those shows so
they're very very interesting but anyway
believe it or not i actually know a
manga and that's death note i actually
know oh amazing amazing
that's really cool um you know i got
questions about this marcus is the guy
who wrote
marcus and this is the 60s it's what was
the name of the paper again repressive
tolerance so they're saying that leftist
should be there it should be tolerated
violence from leftists should be
tolerated but from the right not even
the thought should enter their mind why
that sounds out of balance without a
balanced right and left to function
together you would i would think that
the system would fail okay yeah because
it's they believe that what happens is
that the system is inherently corrupt
and the system is inherently designed to
reproduce itself and only the true
leftist understands how to break free of
the what they called literally they
called this the problem of reproduction
so society reproduces itself by all of
its means and mechanisms so only that
which steps out of the
mechanisms of reproduction is to be
condoned so anything else on the right
what you're doing is
you have a oppressive society a
repressive society a harmful society a
racist society a sexist society a class
of society and if you don't reject that
utterly in fact he called it the great
refusal marcus did if you don't reject
that utterly and step completely outside
of it all you're doing is becoming
complicit doesn't this sound familiar to
the world we live in today you're
becoming complicit in those harms and
keeping those harms going so in some
sense you you bear moral responsibility
for every act of racism that comes up
later in life
in the world
for every act of uh you know
capitalist exploitation or whatever that
happens later in the world if you don't
completely refuse the system then you're
complicit in that so they don't want
balance they think that balance is a
form of compromise that keeps oppression
alive
so you have to have a complete he calls
it again the great refusal of the entire
terms of the existing society and the
question is how do you solve the problem
of reproduction and the answer that they
gave was relentless criticism
problematization of everything
quite literally marcus says that it must
be relentless negative thinking and
negative thinking will become positive
by
actually freeing up the ideal society
that is contained within
the existing corrupt form and we go back
to the alchemy this is alchemy a lot of
people don't know what the religion of
alchemy is about but the the it is a
religion by the way it's a very old many
thousands of years old religious view
and it's that when in the act of
creation god co-creates himself and the
universe okay the exact same instant of
creation
but he makes himself in the universe so
every single thing whether it's his pen
or you know whatever me you the crystal
balls whatever it is on the table
there's some aspect of the divine
contained within that but it's in its
mundane form and so what you have to do
is use the magical spells of alchemy to
break open the mundane form of the thing
so that the divine form can come out
lead is a mundane metal so you have to
do the magic spells break open the
nature of lead at a metaphysical level
and then the seed of gold inside will
transform the entire lump of metal into
gold which is the divine metal death is
the mundane form of existence so you
have to break open and make the elixir
of life that will break open the
death and turn it into life which is
divine and the same thing is being
expressed by marcus in these essays that
he's writing um
especially repressive tolerance here is
that if you break open the form of
society then what can happen is that the
ideal divine version of it heaven or as
henry drew i mentioned earlier put it
the kingdom of god
as it exists on earth can emerge from
the oppressive forms that are trapping
it and holding it back do they
acknowledge that when you break open a
society it can also
you know emulate or i mean they should
listen to gandalf talking to sauron
because he's like whoever breaks a thing
to see how it works has left the path of
wisdom
that's
no they if they're that's the problem is
they think that the world is
intrinsically bad right
so this isn't this turns out not to
necessarily be the hermetic side if we
go back to hegel what did he do he
combined her medicine with another old
religion called gnosticism an old
mystery religion the gnostics believe
that being itself we've been cast into a
prison
by
the character in genesis that gets
called god but he's actually the
demiurge he's actually a demon and so
he's he's not the real supreme being
behind this the scenes and so the whole
whole of being is a prison where you
don't get to be who you want you have to
grow up you have a body you didn't ask
for so maybe you have to transition
maybe it shackles you to having babies
and so you know you have to be able to
have infinite abortion you have to be
able to transform your body this
view that your your very existence in
existence itself is a prison and the
form of society as a prison is the
mindset that they're in so there's no
balance and if all you do is burn down
the prison that's still better
than leaving people in it this is
fascinating i want to say though they're
wrong of course they're wrong life is a
a gift yeah body is a is we've been like
i look at it this way i saw a meme
earlier and it was it was god and the
devil and they were arm wrestling and it
was some political cartoon that said
only a fool would create his own enemy
and then i responded with like when we
program video games we make the villains
on purpose like your argument is is you
know childish um
but this idea of you know your body
being a prison or whatever when we play
video games
you play a character which has limits
it's enjoyable it is done on purpose for
something we want to do
you know you get a character the
character's weak you make it strong or
you start like how many how many women
played mario it's like oh now you're a
guy it's like they don't complain that
mario can't turn into a woman or be a
different character it's like you play
the game you enjoy it life is a gift you
got uh it's not particularly long but
it's long enough in a lot of ways and
you get to experience this this slice of
existence and that's uh that's that's
unique and it's magical so speaking of
video games sorry you know i'll give you
a second but uh
you ever play like so believe it or not
i know last time i was here i was like
don't play video games
but
believe it or not i used to play video
games and i played i got really into at
one point this final fantasy series and
i was playing final fantasy 10 which is
that legendary kind of you know epic
story everybody gets all excited about
it and it turns out that the game is set
up so that you can actually
you know get these crystals or whatever
they are and just keep making your
characters stronger and stronger and
stronger and it turns out i was playing
on my brother's account or whatever and
he left he went out san diego for three
weeks and i'm just playing and i'm bored
like just chilling every night playing
the game and i made these characters
like super strong so even like the
little [ __ ] you know weak um magic
users or whatever they aren't supposed
to be able to hit with their stick very
hard it would hit and it'd be like all
nines and kill everything in one hit and
it's like he came back and he was like
what the heck the game's not even fun
so when you go god mode in a game it's
not even fun anymore exactly it takes
everything away from it and so yeah this
idea that the body is a prison
completely misses the uh the give and
take of reality and of life that makes
life interesting and worth living it's
really a sad and miserable existence and
i do have tremendous pity for people
that are sucked into this kind of way of
thinking um but ultimately i think this
is where that the drive comes from let's
jump to this next story because i'm
again i think this all really comes
together in interesting ways from
post-millennial biden to cancel up to
ten thousand dollars in student loan
debt extend payment pause until december
and there's also going to be a twenty
thousand dollar forgiveness which i
believe is additional if you receive the
pell grant they say um
in addition pell grant recipients will
see up to 20 000 of their debt cancelled
i i read somewhere that it was actually
in addition to but i could be wrong i
think it's 10 on top of 10 is what i
learned is that what it was because
someone someone wrote it was 20 on top
of 10 and they may have been mistaken it
was it was like a mainstream publication
or something but anyway this
ain't it
they're not actually solving the problem
of student loan debt the predatory loan
system will still exist all their all
he's basically doing is giving a tiny
bribe to people to vote for him but i
think the bigger issue here that i'm
interested to hear your thoughts on uh
james is
universities these these schools they
are subsidized indoctrination machines
and now people are getting a freebie so
it's like
they're they're continually subsidizing
in more and more ways they want it to be
free yeah well of course they want to be
free
anybody who's sharing a cult religion
wants you to come and experience it and
if it costs money to support they want
someone else to pay for it so they can
keep funneling people in without
hindering themselves right yeah so i'm
curious what you think about all this no
i mean so this is i mean there's a whole
thing we could get into if you want to
about how universities back themselves
or paint that painted themselves into
this financial corner they're in but
with the students let me just like take
one step back and we'll come back into
focus because it's going to hit both of
the things we're just talking about are
all the things we've been talking about
the agenda behind much of leftist
activism if you read marcusa marcuzza
says in another essay it's called the
scan liberation in 1969 the first
chapter of that it's an essay but it's
like 170 pages long so it's
back in the day kids we wrote real
essays
they weren't like you know
500 words
sorry op-eds no it's 170 pages the first
chapter of his essay in liberation is a
biological foundation for socialism and
what he explains is that if you want to
get socialism you have to change the
level of people's vital needs you have
to change people in terms of what they
need now he has a footnote that says i
don't literally mean biology so he's not
literally advocating for eugenics and
every time he uses the word biological
it has quotes around it so he means
something different by it and what i
finally figured out is what he means by
it is
that you don't know how to live life
without getting your way in other words
psychopathology literally the definition
of psychopathology interferes with your
ability to engage in daily life so
every bit of leftist activism that's
followed off of marcusa which is
basically all of this radical left since
the 1960s
has at the bottom the the goal to create
the activists who are going to
not be able to figure out how to live
their life without getting the policy
change that they demand so in this case
you give all these kids crazy amounts of
student debt and what do they do they
become agitators for student loan
forgiveness and eventually free college
because they want to have the free
indoctrination program and so hand in
glove the colleges become the
indoctrination centers or actually the
programming centers they're more like
maoist thought reform prisons than they
are like indoctrination so you turn it
into a thought reform prison and you get
kids to demand that it be free because
you put them in financial dire straits
now with the trans issues the same thing
because what happens if you transition a
child
put them on puberty blockers stereotypes
you cut them up sterilize them but what
else do you know how expensive you know
how many drugs and
how much medical care they have to take
them for an extremely long for like the
rest of your life no right right so what
are those people going to advocate for
at a policy level
uh-oh socialized medicine because the
medicine's so expensive and the system
broke them and it's so expensive so what
you're doing history uses people and
then discards them sorry
trans activists that's what you're doing
you're using these poor kids and you're
going to discard them
uses people then discards them to get
their policy agendas in place and in
this case you're going to create an army
of people among other things they're
politically moldable et cetera but you
also are going to create an army of
people who are going to advocate
vigorously for the rest of their lives
for socialized medicine just like these
kids in college what's worrying to me
about this is uh we we talked about the
d transition or subreddit where you have
nearly 40 000 people in constant posts
from people about how they're becoming
suicidal because they were rushed in and
didn't want to do it yeah no kidding so
my my whole response to the whole thing
is like whether someone is is trans or
someone is not trans and being pressured
we better slow that thing down before
people start taking their own lives well
now you know
you know one of the main reasons that
they're doing there are a few but one of
the main reasons that they're they're
pushing it so hard is because they need
that army of broken people who are going
to be pharmaceutical patients for the
rest of their life who are going to have
expensive medical treatments we're going
to adv ask for and beg for socialist
medicine i kind of feel that's a bit
a bit of a stretch i think there's a lot
of factors at play there's industry
standards there are money to be made
there's money to be made but there's
money to be made in the short term too
in the long term as well but i think a
lot of these people like if you look at
the mothers who bring their kids to
these shows it's like you've got
munchausen by proxy but then you have
parents who are genuinely genuinely
confused and don't know and think
they're doing the right thing sure of
course of course i think you'll find
within most circumstances you have
normal people being pulled in a
direction yes and it's and it's a much
smaller faction that are probably
nefarious no that's exactly right as a
matter of fact the vast majority of say
the so-called parents of trans kids and
i say that so-called because i don't
believe such things
as trans kids exist um
there are people who've been pulled into
this as as you were suggesting but the
parents a lot of them were like i got a
cyber there i think that's factually
incorrect uh we we we talked about there
there's a there's a an article from a
phd professor who talks about endocrine
disruptors and hormone disruptors okay
which masculinized the brains of female
fetuses and then resulted in trans kids
i think i think how often is that so
maybe they do exist right and that's
that's one in ten thousand one in twenty
two sure i'm not saying it's it's one in
ten i'm just saying okay you know for
you to say you don't think they are they
do exist i think i think we've got i'll
walk back to the very rare very rare i
agree with and i think the the challenge
is
we we have a system right now that
doesn't discern between social and the
actual oh no they're not even going to
try right well it's just
rushing kids into uh medical treatment
which is going to permanently alter and
and for many of these kids we're clearly
seeing now the d transition subreddit
ruin their lives yeah big mistake
because you dangle out
you tell them you have this huge problem
there's no real good solution to it
you're probably going to commit suicide
if you don't get resolution to it here's
this treatment that we here's this one
path out this by the way this is how
they did maoist thought reform is they
put people under outstanding
psychological pressure with a limited
set of choices for how to escape that
pressure and then they go into that and
then what happens is they get four or
five years in and then whoop the rug's
been pulled out from under them they
don't have any options to get out
anymore the underlying problem never got
treated my question is how much of this
is an emergent phenomenon versus a
directed phenomenon oh yeah well um
lots of money goes into it so there's
some directedness to it some of it
though this is what i'm starting to say
a lot of these poor moms were kids in
the 90s right and we all grew up if we
grew up in the 90s we all grew up with
this kind of like boogeyman of it was
real but there was this you know
character that was really heavily
portrayed as the the you know the evil
angry there's almost always an angry dad
who disowns their kids for being gay
right and everybody's like oh that guy's
terrible so you have a whole bunch of
people who grew up in the 90s
who had this character as like the big
evil guy to think of then they grow up
and they're adults now and they have
their children so what are they going to
be hyper inclusive as like an
overreaction then you add in the
munchausens by proxy which is where you
know if people don't know what
munchausen's by proxy is i know you guys
do but it's where you poison your kids
so that they're like sick and then you
pick up the pity points like oh my poor
child so for people who aren't familiar
munch houses is when you feign being
sick for attention and by proxy is when
you faint someone else being sick for
attention yeah often they did like drip
feed their kids poison and say you know
sally's so sick oh my gosh like like a
sixth sense the the the mom yeah i was
poisoning the daughter and then going my
daughter's so sick yeah i think just
wanted to kill the daughter in that
movie but um this is a really important
point too that i think argues for a
potential emergent phenomenon that we're
seeing i've talked about this yeah the
boogeyman's grown up when i was little
we had all these signs everywhere about
how racism was bad
and so all of these millennial kids
around me grow up being told about how
awful racism is they have been trained
to combat racism the only problem is
we've enacted a bunch of policies doing
away with the institutional problems i'm
not saying it's perfect i'm not saying
it's done i'm just saying for the most
part things are pretty good you know
like things have improved dramatically
and now you have these people who grew
up on this seeking it out but they can't
find it yeah so i refer to it as an
autoimmune disorder yeah yeah of course
now it's not really a question as to
whether or not there are people who are
taking advantage of this for for and
these would be nefarious people i just
think they're relatively small a number
who are pushing this uh usually with a
lot of money behind it for whatever
other ends they have and if we might
quote from the great philosophical epic
uh
i guess legend of game of thrones chaos
as a ladder and they know that causing
these points of damage creates
opportunity now i don't think there's
terribly many of those people relatively
speaking the proportion of them might be
as small as one or two percent which by
the way matches the proportion of
psychopaths in the underlying population
i met uh i knew a bunch of people from
occupy wall street i was down there for
a while and um
what i was told by some of the
organizers people with access to the
resources who knew what was going on had
plans and were controlling what was
going on they said we want to flip the
pyramid over
sounds good right
with the pyramid right you got the you
got the elites on top you got the
bourgeoisie you got the proletariat yeah
so it sounds like to the the uneducated
to the unlearned oh you want to put the
working people on top to give them
control right that's what socialism
wants yeah well i'm not one of those
people i responded with if you flip a
pyramid over it's going to topple into a
brick a pile of bricks and then there's
only going to be one or two of the
working class people on top and they're
like right that'll be us yeah exactly
they were not saying that's an
entitlement all of the poor people will
be
on the top and all of the evil owners
will be on the bottom they were saying
once we flip it over it resettles into a
new pyramid with us on top that's right
that's right exactly and that's that
that entitlement we were talking about
previously and of course that attracts
psychopaths because they know that
there's a gigantic opportunity there and
they can create that chaos to flip the
pyramid over and arrange things so that
they end up on top of that that pile and
this is how these things always go that
i mean the bolshevik revolution didn't
create
uh you know this new paradise society
made a very very very small like hyper
feudal society with a very small number
of lords in the communist party you know
i describe it monopolization of power
centralization of power is bad
we have antitrust laws because we're
like this company got too big okay
communism socialism and any kind of
authoritarian government system
skips the process by which power
coalesces and just instantly snaps it
all right to the center yeah okay that's
not good that creates problems
it turns out that the people it puts in
charge are people who are good at
accumulating power they're not people
who know how to do anything but just
people are good at accumulating power
and maintaining power like i learned
recently i was talking with a woman from
she grew up in the soviet union and uh
her family was was fortunate enough to
survive and it fell and then they came
to america in the in the 90s and um
she was saying do you know why they made
us wait in bread lines it wasn't because
they could have set up more bread lines
it's like literally nobody had anything
to do
it wasn't that it was that if you waited
four to five to six hours
in line for for your ability to eat
dinner that night you weren't doing
anything else right you couldn't go do
something else i saw a really
interesting meme someone posted about i
remember where i saw it they posted
about how when they were when they were
younger and in school
the teacher
they were learning they were in the
history lesson and the teacher all of a
sudden snapped at one of the students
and accused them of breaking some rule
they clearly did not break like you were
you're speaking loudly go to the
principal's office and then when the
student was like no i wasn't the teacher
said does anybody else want to back him
up
anybody else wanna wanna put their name
in there and go to the principal's
office office with him defend him and
none of the kids said anything and she
goes okay pack your things go see that's
why they say as soon as he left she said
i know he didn't do anything wrong
but none of you would actually call out
the fact because the authority told you
and you were scared i'm glad that she
made that point because that's why they
say that the the first person to stand
up is i mean it does take courage but
they're not the one who has the most
courage it's the second person who
stands up because they know what they're
in for
that takes the most courage and then
once you get over that hump the third
person that takes less the fourth person
who takes less and on and on and on and
that's how that's how courage actually
works in a lot of ways that's how i feel
about margaret taylor green i feel like
she's a target for the swannings because
she is the one introducing legislation
like she wants to declare james revenge
and ruth sent us which docks the
uh the addresses of the supreme court
justices she wants to have them declared
a terrorist organization this bill is
not likely to pass she does have
co-sponsors but it takes the people who
are starting to
make this part of their central platform
she is very brave but we need more
people to follow suit and that takes a
tremendous amount of courage i don't
think you can in the united states
declare an organization a terrorist
organization she has a bill in congress
for it but i i just think ultimately it
just fails because it's the first
amendment issue
you can you can charge someone with
terroristic acts specific things
and which is what you would need to do
so she would need to
file uh um what is it
a referral for it to the doj on these
people for the crimes committed however
kind of pointless because the doj knows
they're doing these things and you know
i'll mention this too
there are similarities to what happened
to marjory taylor green what happened to
us there are some similarities i'm not
going to get a security because there's
an active investigation in multiple
jurisdictions but um
it was the day after marjory taylor
green was here that we got sweated the
first time
these people have not been brought to
justice but there are as i mentioned
multiple jurisdictions multiple
jurisdictions looking into it i've you
know given several statements and and
evidence so it may be moving forward but
we're going on now seven and a half
months it was january 6 when we got
swatted
now it seems like it may be the same
person or a similar entity going after
marjorie taylor green
where is the doj
are they unable because if they're
unable then we've got a very serious
stability problem in this country if
people can keep doing this yeah
and people know that this is how this
works the people that game the system
that you were talking about they know
how to get into system they know that
the system can drag things out that they
can drag their feet on whatever and they
can create that repressive situation
where one side's strongly favored versus
the other uh by dragging it out when
it's one side and not dragging it out
acting quickly when it's the other side
the fbi would not investigate hunter
biden but they're jumping at the chance
to go raid trump's house yeah exactly
exactly that's what i'm talking about
it's exactly right and right right
before the midterm too no we're not
going to interfere in an election oh the
midterms coming up rate trump yep
exactly amazing and now now there's a
lot of fears there's there's been talk
about whether or not trump would be
willing to make you know announce his
run right before because of what will
happen with the republican party and the
fact that he's been raided by the by the
fbi won't make him look bad and now
there's questions being raised i think
trump should just announce i think we
saw from the from the elections the
other day that the gop desperately needs
trump to be actively involved and trump
should not wait he should just come out
and be like yo we're going to run and
we're going to start endorsing people
i mean he's been endorsing people and
his record is here's i'll i'll say this
in 2018 trump's endorsements were like
50 something percent
in 2020 it was 70 something percent so
far right now trump said like 99 i think
is it like 99
success over 90. overnight it's i think
it's 99. yeah and so high the suggestion
is
republicans lost in 2018
republicans made massive gains upsetting
what was projected in 2020 and with
trump's
you know
endorsements this successful people are
thinking that's an indicator that
republicans are going to win but we'll
see man the democrats uh there was a
swing district new york 19
was predicted to go republican it's an r
plus the three district democrat won
so i don't i don't you know people
mentioned myra flores in texas as like
oh red waves coming because a republican
won a democrat district and i'm like
dude the whole thing's flipped over on
its head we don't know what's going to
happen i think in some ways that's what
the student loan debt reminds me of like
this is a bid from biden's
administration to be like remember
democrats are good the democrats give
you things before midterms and it's just
not quite as successful as they want to
be i would think and i'm not an expert
in this that if you really wanted to
address the student loan debt problem
you'd make it easier to declare
bankruptcy on student loans because it's
almost impossible right now and that is
trapping people in debt that you
wouldn't carry except for the fact that
you are told you have to go to college
to advance to get a better career it
trus it saddles them with debt
immediately while pushing them down a
path that is not giving them any
financial success i think we should uh
forgive interest on all the loans and
apply any interest payments made
directly to the principal but you got to
pay back the principal
that's probably right you got money you
got to pay it the system itself is
predatory and uh the first thing you got
to do here's step one here's the
solution to the student debt crisis for
all the left and the right fans out
there
um first and the loan system it's
clearly predatory all the left clearly
agrees right they tricked you into
getting these loans they're too
expensive you can't pay them back all
right end it
now for everybody's holding debt
interest payments
done no more interest any payment you've
made
that interest will be credited towards
the principal you got to pay back what
you were given but not the interest this
is the best part people get their
student loan forgiveness if you got
money you got to pay it back now if you
paid more in interest than you borrowed
we applied that as a tax credit on your
your taxes for this year and it rolls
over until gone so if you pay 10k in
interest beyond the principal then this
year that 10k goes towards what you
would have paid in taxes so it's a it's
a big win for all of these student that
forgiveness people right but if you were
given five grand and you bought
cheeseburgers and beer with it
and then you paid back half will forgive
the interest and if it's still thousand
bucks left over you got to pay that
principal but the first thing ending the
system of loans
seriously hinders
the the educational institutions
puts us
a big slow down on that and will help
restore to
only the people who truly can and want
to go to college do
if you want to get a private loan you
know from a bank or something to go to
college that's fine you can do that but
the way it's set up right now with these
these these these uh federalized loans
and grants and things no i'm not getting
rid of all that i mean the the academic
institutions are
i'm sure we're all fine with this but
they're they're not going to come out
well from this and the reason that these
loans are the way that they are is
because the academic institutions got
walked not just the students get walked
down a primrose path if you have to go
to college you have to if you want to
get a good job the whole thing the
institutions themselves did too when
when the federal underwriting of student
loans came in in the 90s
they saw this gigantic opportunity to
you know compete for students that they
didn't have before and this is when you
saw this massive shift towards student
services take place in the universities
so they're building rec centers they're
building bowling alleys they're building
movie theaters they're building fancy
new dorms like my dorm was like
literally
designed by a prison designer and it was
about 50 rooms for one bathroom you know
we all shared a shower when the janitors
got mad because one guy like went to the
bathroom in the heater in the in the in
the bathroom so he got pissed and he
took away all of our shower curtains so
we all just had to like shower like
here we are yeah it was like that was
back in the day man um
things were different back in the day so
they started building all these cool new
dorms and all this other stuff and they
got massively massively in debt hundreds
of thousands hundreds of millions of
dollars in mortgage debt and so these
the the the strings we're talking about
the loans being given to the students
but there's massive loans that were
given to the institutions too and then
they were using the loans being given to
the students to try to pay off those
debts themselves now what is happening
the same financial institutions are
playing this esg game
the social part of esg that's
environmental social governance that's
the s and the governance is that you
have to have the right people in places
of power and offices and say diversity
deans and things like that if you want
to have a good score to have your your
finances managed by these exact same
financial institutions
then what do you have to do the same
ones by the way you were going after
with occupy that were too big to fail
turns out they learned that they were
too big to fail and could do whatever
they wanted because they got bailed out
well what are they doing they're now
saddling these universities with insane
administrative bloat so they can't
possibly pay their debts either so what
we're seeing is a recreation of the
company town but the financial industry
is the company and basically every large
institution is the town and then people
that are taking these student loans are
just getting roped in for it i feel like
the end result to all of this is not
going to be what what these woke people
think no obviously not it's an absurd
concept but the end result is these big
institutions that they're bloating are
just going to crumble in on themselves
they have to in the end and
you know what would you do if you had
say this huge
institution like the entire financial
system of the world that's likely to
collapse in on itself and it's
leveraging everybody's pension funds to
be able to do it and what so those are
all are going to be what's going to
collapse what would you work like hell
to put in place if you could before the
big collapse comes why not a gigantic
social control system like surveillance
and social credit systems and all of
this to protect yourself so that you
don't end up like swinging from a lamp
post when everybody's really really
really mad that you wrecked the whole
world's economy you can't it won't work
um yeah it's not going to work
i pointed out how so much of our
information is digital right now that if
the power went out we would instantly
lose access to
all of these databases oh yeah oh yeah
yeah like it's so fragile you had a
bookshelf power went out yet books
there was a funny meme where some guy
was like the future is lame my book just
ran out of batteries yeah exactly like i
was on a plane in my book ran out of
batteries what am i supposed to do
yup i mean that's the end of
space balls right even in the future
nothing works yeah that's the line when
the
self-destruct cancellation button
doesn't work it's convenient that my
phone grants me the summation uh grants
me access to the summation of human
knowledge but uh when the battery dies i
got a brick actually have you heard
about this idea that we're going to
enter a new
historically speaking not for us in the
moment we're not going to live through a
dark age but historically speaking this
is going to be a huge dark age because
everything's digital right so
if you the thing i saw about it was like
well if you write on a clay tablet right
if you scratch or you know kinetic form
or whatever it is on a clay tablet 5000
years later if it didn't break you can
still read it right
well if you put something on like a dvd
which is
far better storage than
say a thumb drive which if like two
drops of water hit it all your data's
gone you put something on like a
physical medium like a dvd
you got 10 to 12 15 years before that
thing can degrade enough unless it's one
of those really really expensive ones
that most people don't use yeah so
what's gonna happen is we have all these
records like you know your wikipedia
entry which we
my wikipedia entry which is which is lit
they're all just ephemeral is it wrong
well
sometimes it changes a lot um i think
you should it's a little bit wrong
at one point though
somebody added that i have gigantic
balls made of brass and that was a
sentence on my wikipedia for about like
four days but it's wrong because it's
titanium that's right yeah the gigantic
part is correct the metal part is
correct they got the metal all wrong
grass is too soft that's right and it
turns green yeah right i thought i was
on to i thought i was right no but i was
talking about this the other day that um
if we got hit by that solar flare that
they've been talking about well we
almost did
well you'd walk into uh
people would like wearing their uh uh
you know leathers with spears and paint
under their faces they'd walk into a
manhattan data center and be like kids
look
knowledge
it could teach us how to find food
how to generate electricity but we have
no idea how to access any of it yeah so
it's gone we almost did i don't know if
you knew that it was like 2004 or five
we'd have to look up the date there was
like the the solar flail flare that
would have destroyed yeah a big big cme
that would have been like
it for our entire grid right
and the way you know everything's
spinning the sun's spinning the earth is
moving it missed by like
if the sun had blown up like 16 hours
earlier it would have been a direct hit
and fried earth wow and that's how much
it missed by and it you know it went off
into space beside the earth the earth
just barely missed it but you know the
us government's got deep underground
bunkers with faraday cage under faraday
cage and protection from nuclear blasts
and all that stuff yeah all your nudes
are definitely in those bunkers that
google's been storing up you think i'm
joking have you have you played the game
fallout 3 no
uh you'd love it um
fallout 3 is one of the best in the
fallout series but it's a
post-apocalyptic and you're in
washington dc like a nuclear war
happened and now there's mutants and you
know ghouls they're like people of like
radiation sickness and stuff and uh it's
it's a it's a real map of dc it's
amazing but there's uh the bad guys or
an element of what you describe as bad
guys the enclave remnants of the us
government who have technology because
they were in bunkers and then there's
other people with technology too but
they're like you know the remnants of
the us government so if there was to be
a major emp nuclear war or some kind of
apocalypse whatever
the governments of the world are
will survive it yeah it's a shadow
government i asked alex jones what's the
difference between the deep state of the
shadow government a couple years ago
before i learned more about the
administrative state actually being the
deep state he was like the shadow
governments in case there's a nuclear
war
they're all they're all ready for it
that was a good impression it wasn't too
bad
yeah you got down there you got deep oh
thanks yeah that was pretty good deep in
the kind of gravelly yeah a little
gravely really real serious real serious
yeah i mean well the next i'll tell you
well the hard drives we're evolving to
do hard drives made out of glass so if
there's an emp you'll still be able to
hit it with a laser and read the data
and also d um dna they're storing data
and dna that's terrifying so i there
there have like been weird conspiracies
about quartz crystals data storage or
energy storage and stuff like that
and
it's it's entirely possible
that there exists
maybe maybe you're a fan of ancient
aliens or whatever it's possible i'm not
saying it's likely or even remotely
likely but there could be ancient data
storage attack that we just assume is a
rock and we would never know if if you
if you gave a hard drive to you know an
amazon amazon tribe with like no contact
with other civilization they wouldn't
know what it was
you could you couldn't even explain to
them how the information is on there no
not even close
i like the idea that in the future men
are proposing with like rings that
actually store all of the most important
data that they have and then they have
to trust that this woman is not going to
lose it like that's how bond strong your
bonded marriage has to be i think i
think where we're headed is that the
woke people are going to line up for
neurolink and enter the metaverse and
that's where they're going to be and if
they're they're going to drag everybody
else in that i mean that's i think the
attempt that there's actually a policy
document from the world economic forum
it's their vision 2025 document that i
read the other day i read such fun
things and uh i'm reading through all of
these you know different visions like
education and technology and all of this
and then i'm starting to read like
comparing against some of the different
articles they put out that they cite and
there's this article that they put out
that said that edtech has failed
them their their vision like they they
wrote a lot of stuff back in like 16
about how important it was for edtech to
rise up and do social emotional learning
and literally like read kids emotions
with like heart monitors and eye
tracking and like all this crazy stuff
that's happening by the way in florida
they're actually doing an experiment in
some counties with what they call heart
math so while you do your math lesson
you're strapped into a heart rate
monitor to find out what stresses you're
at about the math lesson like i don't
want any company having that data by the
way but um
i'm reading this thing and it's like
well what we're learning is that you can
bring education into the metaverse but
not the other way around and so the goal
will be that school is in the metaverse
like if you want your kid to go to
school they're gonna have to slap on a
facebook owned oculus and go into the
metaverse and you know who knows what's
going on in there and
you think you're going to be able to
look over your kid's shoulder and see
what's happening on the ipad no it's
going to be in the metaverse they're
talking about digital travel in that
document you know so nobody's going
anywhere you're only
the plebs have to go to meta room only
the real rich and famous can go to rome
uh for real for example and so they're
actually talking about this though the
travel industry's
way deep into virtual travel could you
imagine like signing up for a cruise and
really do is put you in like a a
classroom with like a drop ceiling and
then you put your goggles on and you
pretend you're at this at sea like yeah
you ever seen those they have these
things you can buy where it's like a
body harness and you're standing on a
bowl and you put on special shoes and
you can actually walk by like the shoes
are touch sensitive or whatever so when
you walk you're actually walking in the
metaverse
i was at um
i was at vidcon years ago six years ago
and they had a big display where there
were two guys up on these things
strapped in and they they're running
full speed but they're strapped in a
body harness and you could watch what
they see and they were playing a first
person shooter against haptic vests and
stuff so you can feel yourself getting
haptic hands and stuff um right now i
think the biggest advancements they made
is they have a lot of different tech
that doesn't really work together very
well to provide a
mostly immersive experience but that
will be a big part of it yeah they talk
about virtual reality and education but
they also like there's another document
this this paper called psycho data put
out by actually a critical theorist by
the name of ben williamson uh 2019 in
the journal of education policy and he's
talking about that the actual point of
all this is to harvest the data that's
the real point and that what what he
argued he's like why are they harvesting
the data well number one they want to
create perfectly forecastable economic
conditions in people so they want to
make you perfect for the market so they
can predict exactly how much money
you'll spend and when and then condition
you to make sure that you meet your
predictions and then secondly is to
control populations uh so the what it is
is a gigantic data harvesting program to
make you think you're playing a video
game or sending your kids to school
and you know right now they're surveying
the kids primarily they have to fill out
these surveys all the time i just like
school just started back so all these
parents are like screenshotting them and
sending them to me on on social media
that's not twitter and they are it's
kind of like freaky the things they're
asking these kids it's like have you you
know do you ever think about racist
stuff you know it's like crazy how often
do you think about suicide they're
asking kids questions like that wow yeah
it's intense and then you know how much
money do your parents make there's all
these crazy intense survey questions
they're asking these kids all the time
uh as a result
of the implementation of social
emotional learning it's almost like
aliens are here you know in secret and
they're collecting data and like
researching us i'm saying almost like
i'm saying it's true i'm just saying
that it feels that way it feels like
we're being we're like chickens in a
chicken coop well i mean so my guess is
is if we are looking at kind of a
revolutionary moment is that what if i
were if i were a communist and i were
looking at the situation i would say
well in the past we've attempted to
build out
the uh the society right the the economy
that was the soviet union we built the
economy and tried to force people to
live in it it was a catastrophe and then
in china we built the people we built
all the revolutionaries and then this
hasn't worked out the way we wanted it
to either what do you have to do you
have to build them both at the same time
so you start harvesting the data while
you program the kids and the school and
then you're building the society based
on the data you're harvesting from the
kids the economy the completely
controlled and conditioned economy and
then smack when the metaverse is ready
everybody's pushed into the perfect uh
the perfect simulation economy will you
control what people can see and hear and
say and you'll control what their
reality is people don't know what they
don't know that's right i would do a
digital tour of one of the great
pyramids of egypt you can go inside and
go down frame by frame and look around
and look at the walls and like i really
feel like i was there sometimes i'm like
i was i i forget that i wasn't in egypt
when i it was immensely awesome yeah so
i mean that's immensely awesome but then
imagine what they could do with that
first of all how do you even how would
you even know if it's really the real
thing right so what if you had gone down
like halfway down the thing you probably
would have been like wait a minute if
somebody had like spray painted a giant
penis on the wall or something like that
but they could insert that in or it
could really be there and then they have
deleted it and you don't know but then
everybody you know we always talk about
the sell the dream side of this wow you
know i had this experience i was in
egypt i got to experience what it's like
to win the super bowl kind of first hand
i get to be on the field i was tom brady
it was so amazing they don't ever tell
you that they could also just import you
into like a torture prison yep they
don't ever tell you that part there's a
movie we've talked about before where
it's like this
they invent this thing they put in your
eye and it gives you experiences
so this woman she like drops it like
nanobots go into your brain and then she
experiences a weekend in aspen and she's
skiing and snowboarding and then her
partner against her wishes makes prison
nanites so like you put in someone's eye
and they experience 100 years in jail
yeah that's what i'm saying five minutes
later they wake up like all messed up
yeah totally messed up like i read this
book it was called
thought reform in the psychology of
totalism by robert j lifton and he was
br he was in hong kong in the 1950s he
published in 1961 and what he's doing is
he's actually interviewing
people as they got out of mao's prisons
in the in the 50s
like literally like a week after they
get out of three years in a maoist
communist prison and he's interviewing
these people and he says that literally
zero people people were affected
differently by the three to five years
in prison in the chinese thought reform
prisons or brainwashing prisons she now
in chinese as they call them and uh
but everybody was affected everybody
came out completely as i mean imagine of
course you would but as a completely
different person
and you could do that digitally we could
we don't need gulags if you have digital
experience gulags and you can't leave
your house because you know you don't
have enough credits like in australia
when they did the covet and if you left
your house like a freaking drone is
following your car or something you know
there's
this isn't
just like hyperbole anymore you're
familiar with the uh
the rat experiment which one the the
hope hope experiment no well maybe took
three cylinders put rats in each one let
them swim until they got tired but
within about 15 minutes the rats gave up
sand to the bottom and died oh yeah then
he took another rats he put him in
once they right when they gave up he
grabbed them took him out dried them off
and let them rest
then picked him back up put him in the
second time around they swam for 60
hours because there was hope they
believed that if they just stuck to it
they would eventually be saved and they
shouldn't give up
and so some have made the argument
following the pandemic and all the
insane things they did
we are still in it we're just in the
hope portion
and this explains why they built
permanent facilities in say australia
and and other places australia's got
this this uh this the howard springs i
think it's called we actually had the we
showed you the shirt earlier
when you're over here
they built permanent facilities it was
for what six months well it was it
existed before it was um uh it was my
place for mining right but i mean like
the the the work that they did
organizing these facilities and setting
them up i don't think was just for six
months yeah
yeah no no i mean
i wouldn't think so either let's let's
jump to the story from uh forbes though
this is interesting california expected
to ban new gas only car sales by 2035
terrible headline forbes what's actually
happening is as of i think today they
have implemented the first steps towards
banning gas vehicles
vehicles will have to be uh zero
emission i'm curious what do you think
this is all about james is this is this
climate change and we're trying to be
better stewards of the earth or is this
some kind of communist conspiracy all
right there's an easy litmus test to
find out if we're being better stewards
of the earth
there's a very easy test are those cars
going to be powered by electricity
generated by nuclear power or not no
because if the answer is no we're not
being better stewards of the earth this
is something else but it does mean they
have easier control of your vehicle
that's right those co those vehicles are
um
in all the cases that i'm aware of
electric vehicles are remote
controllable or they can be talking oh
yeah oh dude so we we uh i got a tesla
and there's like a puddle of water and
you stand back and on your phone you can
remote control the car with your phone
and so i'm pressing the button and the
car is backing away from the the swampy
muck and then i can get in it's amazing
yeah that doesn't mean someone else can
do it yeah it totally does mean somebody
else can do it and it probably means
that you know if he
so felt like it elon musk could probably
do it he literally could just
do it which means that if you know
whatever manufacturer maybe elon is and
maybe isn't gets in cahoots with our fbi
that's acting so well then you could get
in your car and it could just drive you
right down to the field office or into
the ocean or into a tree maybe maybe
maybe you'll get in your car and then
it'll start speeding out of control
without your control 90 miles an hour
down wilshire boulevard slam into a tree
because you're a journalist working on a
story about uh a general exactly yeah
exactly i just think it's it's a funny
image of elon musk like sitting in a
room and then he walks up to a guy with
his hands on his shoulder and goes
execute order
69 and then the guy's like okay and then
you press the button and all the cars
turn on start driving to tesla hq it
would actually be that that would be
there would either be that or it'd be 4
20 6 90. i'm going to say
it would be like execute order for 2069.
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah okay you'll die
yeah so um that reference i made earlier
just a moment ago is actually it's a
real reference michael i think was a
journalist
he complained to a neighbor that he saw
someone messing with his car asked to
borrow theirs they said no he got in his
car
car speeding down wilshire boulevard
slams into a tree explodes he dies
that's right that's right and he was
working on a story i think it was about
was it about hayden
oh i'm not sure i got to look that up
now yeah you want to google that real
quick yeah i remember that actually
that's right
that wasn't an electric car though was
it nope nope but but for the past i
think you know 15 or so years cars have
been remote controllable there's what
people don't understand cars that were
not designed to be remote controlled can
be remote controlled so these car
hackers
i i watched this thing you know we all
knew that self-driving cars were coming
these car hackers took over a car that
did not have any
remote control or self-driving
capabilities because power steering
can be manipulated by the computer
inside the car
michael hastings was uh investigating
cia director john brennan brennan okay
there you go and then his car went out
of control on wilshire and hit a tree
and exploded at a high rate of speed he
thought someone was trying to kill him
it was like 11 it was like 1am he left i
think he left the bar and he was driving
home and then just so he could have been
hammered but you know he's also
investigating the head of the cia i mean
now plausible deniability is all of a
thing isn't it yep yeah no i mean so
this though i mean this is absolute uh
control over over over the population
your control of your movement if you're
stuck with electric vehicles and
and all of this i am proud that i still
drive a car that has like i mean it does
have power steering but it's it has old
school like it has a key there's no
button nice if you actually have to use
it it doesn't even have like a key that
like folds or whatever it's like a
normal key from the back in the back in
the old old days nice mechanical locks
or are they automatic they're automatic
though that's what you got to do but
it's a standard it's a stick shift too
if you're driving
yeah if you're prepping you want a
manual yep like 1960s car
no computer components in it at all
that's what yeah automatic transmissions
hard to fix if you know if everything
fell apart you'd be better off with
manual learn how to drive stick driving
stick is fun you know it depends on
if i'm going to you know what i don't
like i don't like driving stick when i'm
just trying to relax it's like you're
making driving a chore you know what i
mean i don't like driving sticking on
hilly roads like in san francisco
because when i want to but like i want
to shift into first gear on a hill i
start to roll backwards so i'm like
someone's giving me 10 feet right now
because they don't yeah i'm in east
tennessee i'm all over hill so they
don't
they never do that about four feet so
it's like really a rat like that i'm
hitting the clutch to the gas but
putting it jerking forward it's the most
annoying thing i'm sure it's happened to
anybody who's driven stick that you're
on a slight hill and then someone gets
right up on you yeah and then you're
like dude i can't release the brake
right now and so you just sit there and
they're honking at you and you're like
you're going to back up i'm going to
stick i'm going to roll backwards
yeah like that scene at indiana jones i
was like first you throw me the whip
i can't i'm stuck
stuck in fixture so the thing about this
is a lot of people are pointing out the
green movement stuff is just about
saving the auto industry that the auto
industry is such a big component of um
the us economy yeah there's i was
reading that like most millionaires in
the us are people who own local
dealerships
so yeah yeah so i mean this is huge so
what do you do got to make new cars but
if people have cars aren't going to buy
a new car why what's the features not
good enough
now you got to make them do it
california is just pumping their economy
i just tweeted out a thing about sweden
that is building a road that recharges
electrical veal vehicles as they drive
over them yeah i was worried about that
um that seems real well it could i mean
it's uh but you're talking about very
powerful electromagnets in the in the in
the you know
third rail don't walk on it i mean what
would that be like so i mean we have
wireless charging for our phones you
know you'd probably be all right to walk
on it but a massive one are your keys
going to get like sucked up or something
i think it just won't walk on that road
it doesn't seem like it's worth the risk
didn't somebody build that solar solar
uh panel road
yeah i heard about that it was like it's
a terrible idea that makes no sense but
they did it because people are are just
the status of solar roads now solar road
solar roadways was the company that
pioneered it or it was one of the most
popular they made a youtube video that
made no sense yeah it got really good
it's funny because they're like we
should make our road solar panels it's
like why because the roads are exposed
to sunlight it's like okay why don't you
just put the solar panels
next to the roads on stands where
they're not being run over by cars we'll
make them more durable right the
material won't be won't have enough uh
will be too opaque and so it will not
absorb enough sunlight and then they get
damaged and scratched and it refracts
light and then snow gets on it just make
solar panels that can move back and
forth and they're next to the road
you'll save money or build a nuclear
plant there you go yeah that too why
don't they want to build nuclear plants
well
because it's the way out of managed
energy scarcity because
there's
well fusion would be would be wonderful
but uh
the claim is that the waste can't be
managed or can't be managed safely or
it's politically infeasible but that's
not true not true for fusion especially
it's certainly not true for fusion there
is no i mean the waste the the material
inside the reactor
becomes radioactive uh
but
none of the there is no waste it's it's
literally water that comes out of it and
no helium that comes out of it sorry uh
it makes helium it makes healing
hydrogen which by the way helium is a
limited resource this is amazing
it's a win-win big time uh
but it's also a not real right now thing
but nuclear is the way out of the
like in if we if we see this as an
energy transition period to where you
know well maybe we're moving away from
from
you know fossil fuels and we have to go
into something different and it's more
green or whatever
it makes every bit of sense to use
nuclear so the the best answer that i
have is that it is the way out of them
being able to manage the energy economy
the way that they want to manage it and
i mean there are some difficulties with
nuclear but they're not
they're not
like death blows or whatever yeah you
can't turn them on and off quickly you
can't ramp up production or ramp down
production quickly in cycle
so there are some limitations but you
need like one
gas plant to be able to like adjust for
that yeah and main baseline load can be
covered by nuclear so it's like the
escape hatch isn't there so this is why
i use it as a litmus test
is if they're serious about it being
about
carbon in the atmosphere then they're
they must be pro-nuclear but they're
very anti-nuclear and when you read the
explanations for their anti-nuclear none
of them make sense which means that
something else is going on they're also
buying beachfront property something's
really up because they were talking a
lot about carbon footprint and reducing
carbon emissions and also and i'm like
well actually we can pull the carbon out
of the atmosphere deposited onto
palladium
copper gold turned into graphene there's
other ways of turning it into graphing
the carbon dioxide you actually mine the
carbon dioxide out of the air and the
methane as well you take the methane out
turn it into carbon dioxide and then
turn it into yeah i mean i got all index
carbon capture back like 10 years ago i
was really really into it really
interesting now the world economic forum
is talking about nitrogen foot the
nitrogen footprints too much or it's
these f the dutch farmers i think
they're trying to shut down because of
the nitrogen football it turns out that
there is a precedent to that that's very
interesting and we're going to go back
into the conspiracy rabbit hole because
there was a book in 1972 published by
the club of rome called the limits to
growth that is a malthusian book it
believes that human populations in
excess of what the earth can actually
support and it's only a matter of time
till everything collapses they predicted
we run out of copper in 2000 by the way
so they weren't that good with their
computer models that they did in the
late 60s and early 70s but in that book
it actually talks about a that we have
to control the fertility rate so that we
don't have too many people but b that
one of the easiest ways to do is to
control the food supply because there's
not enough food then there won't be as
many people because people won't make
babies when there's not enough food to
feed them and so then what you can
actually need to control is the levels
of nitrogen fertilizer it's explicitly
written in that book now you think well
what's a connection to this well in 1972
this book comes out so what right in
1973 klaus schwab invites them to speak
in the third annual world economic forum
meeting
at davos which one it was called the
european management forum before it was
called the world economic forum 1974
they brought in a
brazilian communist priest
dome elder kamara is this guy's name or
chimera or camera or something like this
i don't know how to pronounce words in
portuguese but it's spelled c-a-m-r-a
helder camaro was the
mentor
spiritual mentor to claus schwabe said
after he met him he was known as the red
bishop he was a communist
but he was also the mentor to paulo
ferrari who is the brazilian marxist
educator and it turns out also to
bergoglio who became pope francis uh so
it's kind of an interesting set of
people that are all involved but camaro
spoke in in 1974 the club of rome spoke
in 1973 and you see this kind of mixture
of this kind of it turns out marx hated
thomas malthus and his ideas but you see
this kind of mixture of marxism and and
and
malthusian ideas kind of percolating
through the world economic forum but
nitrogen fertilizer and the
the buzzword of the book is
sustainability by the way uh nitrogen
fertilizer and the need for a
sustainable world population is the
thesis of that uh part of the book about
farming and so i think that this
nitrogen thing is
um as probably other
agendas behind it of course it can you
also what which one was it was it stalin
or was it london that said if you
control the food you control the people
sounds like something stalin would say i
think that was stalin that said that and
so
i don't know if lenin was as murderous i
think you know do you think stalin
killed london
i have no idea i think he poisoned him i
have no idea i do know though that if i
were like really bad people that operate
in this really bad people space
not saying that that's what's actually
occurring but i would possibly consider
manufacturing a famine and then offer
digital ration cards that get you on
your digital
currency to buy food and then you would
say that people like preppers who stored
food and became self-sufficient are
people who hoarded food and that they're
the cause of the food crisis
and that you're gonna have a uh what was
classes quote prepare for an angrier
world and you're gonna have a very angry
world at that point you guys were close
it wasn't stalin that said if you
control the food you control a nation uh
it wasn't lenin it was henry kissinger
oh guess who's the great architect of
the west and also literally also
literally the mentor of class schwab wow
literally he's looked that up it's cloud
so mentors
must be working together to transition
from the liberal economic order to a new
world order they must be and that's the
connection i've needed between the world
economic forum the united states is
kissinger and klaus schwab look them up
and they're they're they're like two
peas in a pod um and it turns out that
uh china is the model
the chinese system with its surveillance
the social credit et cetera is a social
control model for the world
that's the practice run which by the way
right now seems to be although it's hard
to say because you don't know what's
true coming out of there cracking a bit
people are not happy in in the chinese
system right now
so scary stuff there he also says if you
control the energy you control a region
i believe this is all part of the thing
if you control the food you control a
nation it's funny that we thought it was
stalin and it's kissinger if you control
the money you control the world
these guys why what's kissinger's deal
was he like
an america was he into liberal like the
john locke libert i don't think so my
guess is that he is what you would call
an old hegelian so hegel's cult of of
uh science or whatever you want to call
it of alchemy split into two groups
immediately following his death in 1831
there were the young hegelians and marx
was a young hegelian and
then there were the old hegelians and
they were kind of competing they were
basically the liberal and conservative
versions and so what the young hegelians
believe just look at marx and you can
figure it out what the old hegelians
believed is actually that the ideal
system had been arrived at in 1830s
prussia believe it or not that's what
they believed and that the goal was to
use the dialectical powers or method
that hagel had put forth to spread it
around the world which is what we would
call nation building if we were to say
neocons today so my suspicion is that
the neocons why are the rhinos so much
like the democrats is because they're
actually both hegelian in their
orientation you have the the old ones
who believe that i don't know it's the
end of history and the last man was the
title of the 1989 book by francis
fukuyama that you're then going to
spread democracy of the american style
around the globe you're going to do
nation building and color revolutions
and take over one nation after another
in order to get there and then on the
other hand you have the marxists
competing with them as two sides of the
same the same program what is dialectic
you've mentioned that a couple times you
said the dialectic nature what is that
the dialectic is a combination of
opposites to lift up to a higher level
of understanding so they'll
intentionally create an opposition in
order to get something to the next level
correct they call it sublation in
marxism wow we're gonna go to super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel and share the show with
all of your friends if you really are a
big fan and head over to timcast.com for
the members only uncensored portion of
the show that goes up monday through
thursday at 11 p.m it should be really
fun tonight with dr james lindsey who is
was here
raymond g stanley jr says tim chris
never needs to speak again if this is
the kind of content we'll get with cast
castle bravo reactor hilarious opening
the one-liners had me rolling quote just
be careful you don't eat it
yes
the first episode uh the next episode is
going to be really really good i can't
spoil it because they're all really
funny but marjorie taylor green
is it was our guest and she did a bit
with us that's really really good and um
extremely esoteric but um it's gonna be
really funny and then uh we we just
filmed something with james it's really
funny which i don't want to spoil but
you know he was fighting chickens okay i
think i just spoiled it oh yeah he
spoiled it but i didn't spoil exactly i
only imagine i'm looking forward to this
one this one's gonna be really funny
i've made lots of friends he made lots
of friends yeah yeah he did i don't
wanna i said too much already but uh but
yeah a lot of funny stuff is coming and
uh you know appreciate it
all right logan culver says james your
speech at okay university on i got to
stop
logan you said d-e-i i don't know what
that is i know what d-i-e is so i'll fix
it for you he said your speech at oak
university on die diversity inclusivity
and equity was amazing i've listened to
le sencoism part more than a dozen times
everyone head over to new discourse new
discourses and subscribe cheers to one
of my favorite guests on irl do you want
to elaborate on what that was about okay
yeah so first
when you asked me to introduce myself i
always forget that i don't i should tell
people i have a website which is
newdiscourses.com that's the name of my
company this name on my podcast you
should probably go to that and i
appreciate it especially now that i'm
off twitter and appreciate the support
so yeah i had a guy his name john or
mark ously is john marcus's full name
ously
in oklahoma who arranged for me to go
during their diversity
inclusivity and equity week they had a
week dedicated to it at ou he arranged
for me to give a talk on the subject at
the university during their celebratory
week of the marxist program and i just
laid out that this is what this is this
is a
equity is the goal equity is a
rebranding of socialism it's an
administered state that's going to
redistribute shares to make citizens and
groups equal that's socialism by
definition okay and diversity and
inclusion are the mechanisms to create a
a set of commissars diversity means
diversity hires for diversity who are
experts in diversity in other words
people who are political operatives for
the program and inclusion means that
anything that upsets those people has to
be excluded so people feel included a
kind of an inversion there of the
meaning of the word and so that
justifies your censorship and purges and
so what you're seeing is the
sovietization of your university and so
yeah i let it rip in that uh i really
let it rip in front of that audience and
anybody wants to go find it the audio is
not awesome but it's out there when i
went to university of oklahoma just
people people really need to understand
it's diversity inclusivity and equity
for die yeah see i actually will make a
case for dei because that spells dei
which is god in latin oh that's not an
accident yeah i don't think that's an
accident either but i do love when they
throw jay in there for justice and make
it jedi because they're such dorks d-e-i
is latin for god it's well deus and
day-e yeah day-e is though that's right
i know about you know dave's day yeah
j-e-d-i
yeah sometimes they put an a in there
for different things and it's idea
oh man
oh yeah or jedi i keep trying to figure
out how they're going to get belonging
and then something that starts with n
which i can't figure out what it'll be
and it'll be biden oh yeah
but justice equity diversity inclusivity
yeah they're like don't you want to be a
totally dude yeah really like they're
gonna they're gonna go for wizard next
you're a wizard harry
all right monumental madman says the tim
fourth super chat please read brian
flowers is gunning for betty thompson's
seat in congress would really love for
you to have him on the show he's an
america first republican freshman on a
mission
interesting
omg puppy says student loans the
democrats are giving money to their
voters and taking it from the trump
voting working class also hi james
correct yeah i want to know where it is
where that money is coming from that's
part well speech he didn't talk well no
no it's fractional reserve banking the
money the the money is created upon
issuance of the debt of the loan
they write the money into existence
instantly diluting the economy paying
that money back is good for
keeping things in working order but as
part of this
reducing debt by 10 000 for every person
meaning that they're going to print ten
thousand dollars per person and give it
to the colleges or the loan institutions
or they're just saying sorry guys you're
not getting your 10 grand back per
person
so
the people people who ever loaned the
money which is for me which is like
fannie
right
you're just not getting that 10k per
person back or are they saying we're
gonna print 10k per person from the
federal reserve and give fannie mae the
10k that's actually a good an important
question that's a big important question
yeah are they are they like federal
loans where they're like we're going to
just forgive it and say you don't got to
pay it back which does create problems
on the system or is it private entities
that did these loans and they're going
to pay them
i want to know i wish biden had told me
in his speech where he talked all about
it today super helpful
falcon laser says james what do you
think of event 201 if you don't know
what it is google it and read the first
paragraph on the first link to come up i
don't know what that is you don't know
that's where they simulated uh the
pandemic like two months before the
pandemic yeah like october 2019 they're
like simulating what would happen if a
coronavirus pandemic phrase specifically
were to break out and then what would
they do to get all the messaging on on
par and like all yeah so we're lucky
they did that i mean
that this is uh hopkins yeah partnership
with the world economic forum and bill
and melinda gates foundation yeah it was
just in time it was really remarkable it
was literally just in time it's just
nuts i'm grateful what do i think about
it
huh
i don't know who is it in partnership
with again johns hopkins in partnership
with the world economic forum and the
bill and melinda gates correct you know
i trust those organizations completely
like wow absolutely we're lucky they're
they're working here to help us
all right dr roller gator says hi james
this is gator are you done getting in
trouble yet
no uh
hi gator it's not even in caps it's this
fake news that i know i agree
all right let's grab what we got
hashtag free dr relegator so we don't
have dead air seriously john kersten
says what people call double standard is
actually repressive tolerance that's
right it's hierarchy it is in fact
them flouting that they have the power
to have a double standard because
they're entitled to feel better than you
and they so they get to they get to skip
the rules and you get to have the rules
and it's it's it's hierarchy it's not
hypocrisy so when you have all these
republicans that are come out and be
like oh look at the hypocrisy actually
all they're doing is like giving them
you know like a slap on the back like
good job guys uh you know the the left
is proud of the fact they they actually
do
not your average like person your
average wine mom
doesn't feel this way but if you
actually pay attention a lot of them
fully believe that they are superior
human beings what did what did sam
harris say about the the the so-called
deplorables or whatever first of all
they're called deplorables what did he
say there was like was it 10 million
absolute morons or something like that
was his comment about what would happen
if we didn't like condition democracy
through fortification of twitter or
whatever like
seriously
james eaton said heard an ad on the
radio that basically said not to do
drugs because drugs because they could
be laced with fentanyl got me thinking
about the poison during pro
prohibition yeah you guys know about
that right
yeah they what what did they do they
they put uh menthol or or what
i forget what they put in i don't know
what they put in but yeah they they
people booze with with poison and make
you go blind blind yeah i think it's
menthol possibly with alcohol oh uh
ethanol methanol methanol methanol oh
yeah what does it say yeah methanol
no that's what biden took out of the
cigarettes yeah yeah yeah
methanol
yeah methyl freaking metal methyl
there's ethyl and methyl ethyl is like
your ant ethyl you can drink with your
ant ethyl right you can't drink with
your amp methyl there is no amp methyl
that's how you remember methane ethanol
and methanol
yeah the the yeah there's two names for
the same thing there you go we got there
eventually
zareel says it's so simple all of this
luciferianism only a path from the dark
to the light don't be caught up in the
small steps yeah yeah it's the same
story as in genesis 3. it is it really
is because it's narcissism and that's
what's in genesis 3. that's what
that's what lucifer
whether you believe in the bible or not
or whether you believe in the the
christian worldview or not if you think
it is just a mythology this is exactly
what the myth is talking about
what exactly uh everything that's
happening where so if you look at
marxism as a theology what it's doing i
remember i told you about hegel with his
absolute idea well marx believes that
man can become absolute man that
remembers it so for marx i have to back
up one instant the the idea exists in
the head of man and so that's why he
says that the hegel had it upside down
and so
you can have the absolute man who holds
the absolute idea in his head so me that
man which is all man remembering that
he's a species being or a communist
a being that lives for the species
actually holds the absolute true nature
of mankind in other words you can
actually actualize man as god
and that the way that it works is
through powers like the state so in
other words
occupying you know worldly authority
positions of worldly authority because
if you if you understand the christian
worldview on it god has absolute and
true authority satan is excluded from
true authority and therefore he occupies
positions of false authority uh through
deception and antagonism and so the myth
of what satan or lucifer represents is
exactly characteristic characteristic of
what marxism actually
boils down to it's it's freaky how tight
it is have you read revelation i have
read revelation you when bloody didn't
put an s on the end of it right what
what do you think about uh what's going
on today and people have drawn parallels
between you know first of all let's be
cautious we should be very very cautious
with with jumping into not the
discussion of it but of believing that
now we're seeing end times play out this
is and what the reason i say is many
times at other points in history people
have said this and people have believed
it and they've read the signs and
they've been wrong
now
i would also suggest that i do and i and
i say this that i know this there are
people who have lots of money have huge
purses that are funding many of the
things that are happening in the world
that seem very nefarious um you can look
up for example ronnie chan and see some
of the things that he's
purchased and funded who actually
believe it is they're in a they're kind
of a christian offshoot cult and they
actually do believe that their objective
is to trigger right the rapture by
by doing the things in revelation and so
some of these things may be coincidental
some of these things it could possibly
be i wouldn't jump that's something that
i think should be met with tremendous
skepticism in general of course without
even dipping into the fact that i'm not
religious so i don't i watched it an
interesting lecture on it and they
explained that
it it may not be uh a prediction of the
future it may have just been been a
description of societal issues that
occurred that they were explaining like
these are the things that happen when
bad things are like when your society is
falling apart basically he was saying of
course many people believe it's prophecy
the word of god it's a prediction of
what's to come or how it will come but
it may have actually been looking at
what had happened already and saying
here are the things that take place when
your your civilization is falling apart
what is it like frogs raining from the
sky and stuff i don't know i don't think
that no there's like
no there's like in order to buy and sell
you have a mark on your hand and
forehead and stuff like that yeah and
then the the you know the the four
horsemen of the apocalypse come riding
out and you know visiting calamity on on
man that they're
and that and that could be metaphorical
yeah it sounds like a fever they're
literally like a psychedelic no no no
experience no no no it's it's literally
a translation of a translation of a
translation that may be saying like hey
when your society starts breaking down
you're going to see famine death war and
these things yeah and they
metaphorically refer to them as the four
horsemen got it not that they're but
then people read the stuff and they
literally believe that there's guys in
the sky and horseback going
on
the thing is with with people that are
operating within that kind of alchemical
mindset is that they actually do believe
that they they could they can take a
road map like the book of revelation and
manifest that thing in the world and so
they it's like reading rev there there
are people who have read the book of
revelation and have decided that that is
a strategy a political strategy
and
it would not be surprising to see many
of the features of that
come into the b come into being if
they've read that as an instruction
manual
all right kent yuger says james do you
notice any parallels between the us
today and 1980s soviet union senile
leader and recalcitrant member states
estonia latvia lithuania acting a lot
like texas and florida that's a great
word
it's funny because that's happening at
the end of the the soviet union as it's
kind of winding down and
falling apart and it's kind of happening
at the front end of whatever is going on
you know if if the world economic forum
is what we fear it is and it captures
power then we're at the beginning of a
new like super soviet uh ussa or
whatever we want to call it and um
we're actually saying
and so now
what we're kind of seeing then is it's
kind of playing playing its role
backwards i don't know there's parallels
all over the place i actually
firmly believe that they're combining
the kind of soviet tactics uh top-down
control public-private partnership etc
with the kind of maoist tactics that are
bottom-up and cultural revolution so
that's your bottom-up and inside-out
transformations and i'm using those
terms by the way top down bottom up
inside out on purpose because that's
when van jones was
the green jobs guy for obama that's he
went on tv and said this is our strategy
is top down bottom up inside out
transformation we have control of the
top down and he said we need you guys to
be the bottom up and the inside out i
wanted you a correction it's
ussa okay united uh socialist soviet
states of america yeah we need more s's
yeah
but it's run by klaus so we have to use
that asset thing in german what the
double s thing that looks like a broken
b oh yeah yeah it looks like a goofy
beta from the greek letters yeah i like
that you have to use it all right tyler
price says yo yesterday i searched for
tim cast music on youtube and the second
search result was will of the people by
muse hello i'll love the show keep it up
yeah you know um we had talked about
that a while back that um the first song
we put out was in 2020 will of the
people by tim cast you can check it out
on youtube
and uh
just recently earlier this year mews
announced their album well the people
and their ad for their song is like a
live action remake of our song and it
was just like the same name the same
color scheme the same themes the same uh
illusions people with hoodies on pulling
down the statue with an orange sky
and throwing ropes even the timing of
how they threw the ropes because we did
an inversion trick where it's like we
showed the future in the past they did
too
and then we were talking about how like
we were working on this album with a
bunch of songs and we do and um i think
ultimately we decided it was it was we
just want to do our thing because we
were talking about okay we're going to
be releasing our album will of the
people at the same time they are because
their album's coming out on friday and
our songs are being released but we just
there's a lot of things that came into
play one
i don't care to be involved in any kind
of whatever dispute it is they're trying
to do but now when you search for our
song you get muse like i feel like that
was intentional like that's they're
they're a major label band they know
that we had gotten several million hits
and there's a free ride coming you know
whatever uh
but you know what we we're gonna do our
own thing and just just steer clear of
stupid drama well i'm not i thought the
song was kind of crap dudes you guys
like the beautiful people the will of
the people i mean it's just a ripoff of
marilyn manson the song that's what
everything and your color scheme on your
song will of the people it's crazy it's
not just the color scheme it's the
actual our our video starts with an
orange sky and ropes hanging from a
statue and then people in hoodies are
throwing the ropes over it and then the
next scene changes to the statue not
being pulled over and then the ropes get
thrown like we did an inversion on the
time thing and and their video is
like i would say it's 85 the exact same
thing that's uncanny
yeah i don't feel i don't feel any of
that and say this political
philosophical space like i certainly
wouldn't ever believe that people listen
to what i say and then like three to
four weeks later put out you know
basically the same video like they
thought of it or you know write the same
book like they thought it was is it
never later
nuts if that happened it was it would be
crazy if that happened they released the
promo like a you know they released the
promo on my birthday right
they released it on you know two months
ago yeah yeah it was like
your birthday or like the day no i'm
pretty sure they released it on uh look
up the will of the people promo it's
march 9th i'm pretty sure june 1st is
when the video went live right promo the
promo i'm pretty sure that was like a
copy so this is the crazy thing where
i'm like dude there's no way that was an
accident yeah that's the same name same
color same themes similar characters
same time like time
theme on my birthday they release it's
kind of like i'm a big fan dude but it's
things like that where it's like should
i believe we live in a simulation or are
they just ripping me off i mean ripping
off is the the less burdensome it's a
more parsimonious assumption yup cannot
find the date five months ago i'm pretty
sure so i think it's on twitter you know
whatever okay yeah but i was like wait a
minute that's my birthday on what it's
like a very strangely strategic time to
do it there's no way yeah like
i don't know how that's an accident all
those things lining up well i'm like
why'd that why that to you and the thing
is now like if you search for tim cast
will of the people which we've been you
know promoting especially now with the
release of the next song coming up uh
muse comes up instead of us that was
what they did it's like okay great
whatever man is it weird to have this
like major band trying to ride your
coattails well i don't know man i'm a
fan of muse um but i think one thing is
clear
let me read this i never says tim's new
single only ever wanted this coming
august 26th
uh man the left is really really
reacting to this
so we but but no this is interesting and
actually i'm curious what your thoughts
on this so we put a promo up on uh on
twitter yeah and youtube and instagram
and it's got like 800 like almost
getting close to a million
views on just the promo which is just
really crazy i mean
but on twitter
all the all these leftists are coming
out and they're attacking it
relentlessly
my view is you know it's partisan they
hate you they don't care what you do or
why you do it they're gonna rag on you
but one thing i think is that they're
genuinely threatened by this what we
produced is major label quality
general interest music it's not
political at all that's a big threat
when you make a song called fjb that's
fine it stays within the confines of of
the the
of the current culture war parameters no
one who makes an fj a song called f joe
biden is likely going to convince a
democrat voter to support them because
they approached them as an enemy so
these democrat voters instantly see it
as a weird right winger
we made a song that is completely
apolitical and just
i uh uh the promo came out and people
are saying it's like emo or whatever and
like i think that's probably a fair
assessment but the song itself is
nowhere near that because that that part
is just like a small portion yeah most
of the song is like ambient soft you
know pop
um i think it's similar to like cosmic
love by florence in the machine okay but
um
what i think and you heard it yeah i
think they're genuinely threatened by
the fact that we here at teamcast are
actively producing a political content
that will be attractive to regular
people oh yeah that's totally something
i mean i don't know but that 100 makes
sense to me because the idea that you're
going to attract
people who are going to think wow you
know this song really hits i like it
who's this tim guy i'm going to look him
up oh he has a show and you know watch
it i'm gonna watch it oh wow he's saying
some interesting things that you know
narrative control and keeping people in
their silos is really really really a
big important thing for them it's a very
important issue to keep people you know
to where
you know well tim has this huge
following and you know james has his
following but it's only their fa like
keep it isolated keep it keep it
contained and something that goes
general interest you know it's really i
mean it's like how how viciously i got
attacked when i'm dr phil because it's
like all of a sudden i did something
that hit you know
you're in the mainstream in the main
regular people are seeing you as normal
and approachable i don't know if they
saw me as normal inappropriate well and
i think the left sees themselves as the
arbiter of art right they have to be you
guys can't produce art because you know
if you're moderate or conservative like
you're not you're not correct you they
have to be in control of art so the fact
that you would make a song is
threatening to them like you're using
their material well this is what they
consider that same mechanism that's
right is because if they can whoever the
artist is general
general appreciation it gives you
emotional feeling you know you connect
to it and then you're going to come back
and see who created it and you're going
to find out what they think and that's
something to terrify if you actually
read their theory you know even these
essays i mentioned by marcus talk about
the need to control aesthetics
aesthetics are everything aesthetics are
so important does he really want to have
have control of art there's a big
challenge too in how they paint people
as
negative things they say everyone's alt
right or far right but what happens so
so here's an example right so i showed
that tweet from vosh where he was like i
make a million dollars a day clearly
he's not serious and then i tweeted
something ridiculous there are people
who immediately took that tweet and said
tim poole opposes debt forgiveness even
though i have never opposed that
forgiveness i have always supported
student loan forgiveness i have always
just had like here's a practical
approach i agree we should do it here's
how we can do it
but they only ever respond to me as if i
oppose it because in their world does it
matter if i'm four or against it i am
against the revolution therefore i must
be in opposition to it yeah yeah they
they want to lie about you they want to
control the narrative of who you are
what is kidding what if and i'm not
saying we will but what if tim cast
records someday maybe friday maybe not
produces a billboard hit
all of a sudden now the establishment
industry is going to be like okay what
is this song and why is it you know
making the top charts
it's hard for you to control the
narrative when regular people don't care
about your narrative when they're just
like i love that song that sounds so
cool yeah but that guy's a fascist what
like imagine if people were like dude
don't listen to post malone that guy's a
fascist yeah they'd be like what
definitely post malone's great that's
that's ridiculous you need to get into
cultural spaces that's that's a big play
that we're trying to do and uh the daily
wire clearly with movies and everything
as well right
all right
paul thunkam says pbs did a special
where they got a hack to a hacker to
hack into a car the only connection was
bluetooth device plugged into cigarette
light to a cigarette lighter
yup
that's crazy joseph mcfarland says all
vehicles post 2009 have varying degrees
of telemetry installed which can be
remotely interacted with even to your
detriment no off switch
welcome to the future ladies and
gentlemen
jack attack says fools nitrogen is not
needed plants need brondo because it has
electrolytes that's right electrolytes
or plant plants you mean like water from
the toilet yeah
logan davis says tim you guys have to
check out sandman on netflix legit the
death episode of sandman is one of the
best things i have ever watched ever i
just have you seen it no there's there's
annoying like woke stuff it's like
whatever i don't really care as long as
it's not they're not beating over the
head with it it's fine but uh the
episode on death was a masterpiece yeah
i didn't really care for anything else
except for that episode yeah i mean it
really feels like a short film that is
so interesting and it's just worth the
watch i can't say you should watch the
whole thing but definitely watch that
episode i think if you uh if you uh have
you have you watched the orville
i know what it is you should watch it i
should watch lots of things you should i
keep telling everybody i don't watch
anything but so so i did see yeah
i think seth macfarlane has now done
three episodes on why it's wrong to
transition kids or does he put out a new
one there was a well in this season i
think there's two and in 2017 there's
one where they transition a baby and
seth like seth's like you want to
perform a gender change sex change
surgery on a baby that's unethical and
they're like in my society it is
completely ethical and we should do it
and he's like i won't let you i want the
doctor do this then the kid grows
because they they lose because this
culture is allowed to do it then they do
an episode this season where the kids
like this is not right i don't want to
be this way and wants to de-transition
and so they agree like we're going to
help then the next episode is the planet
is trying to kidnap they're trying to
smuggle women off the planet to stop
them from undergoing child sex changes
it's like
you know the transitioning of baby
things is literally where gender
ideology or actually gender identity
started that's what john money did right
that's literally what john money did
uh seth macfarlane's parents taught this
prep school near riger up called the
kent school and it was one of the early
independent boarding schools to approve
of a like official trans student policy
so i'm wondering if this is something
he's seeing reflected in like the school
he graduated from
all right let's uh let's grab a couple
more tyler price says maybe mews did it
to try and send their fans your way
because of the name and it was released
on your birthday as a present ha ha sure
well it created serious market confusion
for us and uh makes it harder for people
to search for the song which they're
telling us over and over again they
can't find it because muse buried it and
uh it's it's crazy i mean the imagery of
it is is this the color scheme if i told
you hey i made a song it's uh it's
called will the people check it out it's
uh the image is like an orange sky with
a statue being pulled down and there's
people throwing rubs and hoodies you'd
go oh okay and then you'd find muse
that's amazing there's no way that was
an accident
that was a dick move guys
anyway
waffle sensei says hey tim kind of
random but i want to know did you watch
the new dragon ball super movie it was
so good bro it'll take you back to the
good old days i almost did i was at the
i was at a mall and they had it playing
but nobody else wanted to see it but i'm
a big fan i'll check it out i heard its
power level is over nine thousand
all right let's see
waffles goes on to say but how do they
procreate in sandman the lore is amazing
but literally everyone is gay how do
they procreate in this world that's
actually a really funny point um in the
show i think what is it 80 of the
characters are gay
what the heck well gay men can have sex
with gay women
well i mean
it's just like
i don't know if that's how it is in the
graphic novel or whatever but i was
watching and i was like okay now hold on
there a minute like i have no problem
with
uh you know when they have like a black
actor play a character that was
originally white like i don't care about
that actors can play whatever they want
to play unless it's in
and unless it's part of the character's
character's identity like if you're
doing the grand dragon super villain
who's a clan member and you make it a
black actor play it i'd be kind of like
hey maybe that's not a good idea
but if you make all the characters by
choice gay then i'm just like
why like it's just it's just
this is weird
you know like you know i i actually
think it's it would be better if there
were straight and gay people like you
know representation or whatever weird
when it excuse heavily
in only one direction it's not
representation it's overcompensation
they feel like other you know
productions haven't
had enough uh get representation so they
need to go out of their way to make sure
you can see it i don't know ladies and
gentlemen if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and share the
show with your friends head over to
timcast.com sign up become a member
we're going to have an uncensored
members only show coming up at about 11
p.m you don't want to miss it and uh
check out timcast records on youtube you
can search for it right now
uh friday at 1201 am the music video
will go live and if you're wondering why
that is it's because we're learning as
we go and that's when billboard starts
tracking music and i'm not i'm not going
to come out and be like oh yeah we're
going to be top billboard or anything
like that it's like no but at least
we're going to you know make sure we're
you know working in the system how they
track songs and doing all that so in the
event we do release a good song we can
get more attention for it but i think
it's a really good song i think you're
gonna like it carter banks did an
amazing job and i'm really excited for
it and then uh actually the version the
promo that we have up has a a rock
ending you know it's kind of heavy but
we also do have a lighter version which
is going to be going up at some point as
well which is more like piano violin and
uh once you hear the song it's like the
promo actually doesn't do it justice
because it's a very very different song
that promo was just the ending of the
song so i liked it i like i liked the
song yeah it's like it was like ambience
it's our first review yeah
yeah the song is mostly just like
i liked the song james lindsay i like
the song it's good that that's proof
that's really fantastic and on the album
you know ultimately what it comes down
to is
a lot of we've seen a lot of bands
release political songs that clearly get
play and that's good because it pushes
back on culture but if we can start
producing regular mainstream appeal
music and it starts dominating we're
going to start shifting narrative
control yeah the reason why crosby
steals nash and young ohio was so good
is not because it was about the kent
state shooting in ohio it was because
they were doing four-part vocal
harmonies and the melody is incredible
what i'm saying is just enough to
pretend long too much
if we can
you know strive to be the best and we
start getting you know positioning in
the music industry it will force
the culture to talk to us it will bring
them to our corner where we get to share
these ideas and it will appeal to
regular people who will be forced into
our corner so i mean one of our
hypotheses is that everything's
political so if you make something
apolitical they don't know what to do
with it exactly falls right outside of
their paradigm oh yeah the lyrics are
very very simple it's just a song about
it's like it's like a song about
relationship
your typical old song like something
like adele would write anyway james you
want to shout anything out yeah since
i'm no longer on twitter
don't go there like just leave that
place because it sucks no i'm just
kidding i don't care use twitter all you
want but it does suck that's true i am
at conceptual james on the other social
media platforms my company is new
discourses newdiscourses.com
and uh at new discourses on social media
i should have within a month or so
another book coming out if anybody's
excited to learn about how education got
stolen and i literally mean that we've
had our education stolen from our
children the title of the book is going
to be the marxification of education and
i'm aiming you know middle of next month
by the latest so
hopefully we can get that going right on
i'm hannah brimlow i'm a writer for
timcast.com you should check it out
every day click on the read tab to see
stuff from me and our other writers uh
you can also follow me on instagram at
hannah claire dot b thanks so much uh
i'm ian crossland from ian crossland.net
follow me anywhere on social media and
just to get that the name your book
that's coming out next month or
thereabouts what's it called the
marxification of education
cool all right thanks james great to see
you again man yeah man very cool to have
you again james we just read cynical
theories that was an amazing book
excellent excellent work on that one for
sure i'm excited you're having another
one coming out soon um thank you all for
joining us tonight you guys can follow
me on twitter and mines.com at
sourpatchalets as well sourpatchlets.me
i just got a craving for 7-eleven nachos
for something oh
all right everybody we will see you all
over at timcast.com thanks for bringing
up
you